dropping on you [ __ ] [ __ ] that
little skinny white chick that people
show up to play with what's her name i
don't know oh uh what's her name taylor
i don't i don't even know one of her
[ __ ] songs that's how out of [ __ ]
touch i am you've heard it on the radio
i don't listen to the [ __ ] radio sing
one i don't know anything i listen to
unless they play it on ozzy's boneyard
uh lithium i only listen to
whatever that [ __ ] [ __ ] is jimmy
florentine's show jim norton show yeah
seriously
that's all i'll even listen to open
anthony i guess this is the floor
whatever the [ __ ] i don't listen to
anything that they talk on
i listen to music in my [ __ ] car and
there's never no nothing new it's
lithium it's old [ __ ] uh ozzie's
boneyard the 80s the one after that uh
classic uh rock whatever the [ __ ] it is
classic rewind you got the final one the
vinyl classic vinyl and every once in a
while i put on studio 54 which kind of
blows they have one or two good songs
every [ __ ] three hours like a dynamic
groove is killer or sylvester what's the
groove the one under the channel i think
it's under it 51. then like 48 has that
one radio show with the black people
[ __ ] the best show i've ever heard in
my life i don't even know what the [ __ ]
the whole hits or something
r b there's a bunch no they play like
one song per podcast
and they're just three black guys that
just torment people i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is what's up with you uh
johnny television how much tv you
watched this weekend not much just a
little much just found it yeah we found
out there was it was only like 10 30
minute episodes
10 30 minute episodes
we went to the la faire which is a lot
of fun right it's great we're there all
day all right walked around you had a
good time what'd you do saturday
uh
we i i took the stars that you gave us
so yeah we just took that and kind of
hung out what did you do yesterday i
didn't see you nothing nobody sees lisa
yet no more
we see each other every day through
sunday
i don't know
i have no idea what's more [ __ ] tv i
i don't know
shiny you're [ __ ] walking vitamin d
deficient and you got the time i'm gonna
be vitamin d deficient no matter what i
do i don't tan i
you got to get out and get sun first
thing
how can you sit in that [ __ ] house i
want you to go easily they have ac where
they go that's great and smell that
[ __ ] sofa seat smell yours and hers
and ask yourself what the [ __ ] am i
doing this wrong
feet [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] oh yeah i
got the one with the i got a recliner on
it it's great sure you do smell that
[ __ ] thing tonight no i don't have to
deal with it you say i'm there with 27
years old in all weekend
watching parks and [ __ ] recreation no
this is what i'm talking about
this is unbelievable to a guy like me
like i don't even understand first of
all we watched one season ahead like
only a few episodes
it's the [ __ ] weekend how many times
did you drill it a bunch no how many i
don't know how many and not every day i
go every day i know you didn't you don't
have the balls to ask every day ben
doesn't have to ask
bend the [ __ ] over you [ __ ] papa's
coming to town the king jew
that probably wouldn't do well just take
you just no but it's not it's not i mean
i ask but it's also you probably invited
her for the weekend when she got a
period too and waste that [ __ ] time
we have sex when she has her period
that's disgusting why
really with everything you'd look at
[ __ ] mexican blood all over the place
looks like viva sabato was going all
over the place disgusting
jesus you don't do with girls on the
pier doug listen when the girl is on
that period i don't want to see the
[ __ ] you understand me not even from a
distance not even from afar i could
sniff out [ __ ] period we just watched
this
peanuts and get all creepy and [ __ ] we
did watch the episode of the sopranos
where juniors go into boca and then
everyone makes fun of them for eating
[ __ ]
that's a great episode that's a great
[ __ ] episode that's the episode that
changes the series really because if uh
his if tony's wife had been quiet had it
hadn't
like told like the secret and tony
didn't lose his temper on the golf
course then no bad [ __ ] would have
happened right everything bad happened
from that episode
the because the mom and junior put the
hit out on tony yeah everything bad
nobody better than the mom in that
series oh my god he's so scary she's the
best there's some good [ __ ] tv now on
those netflix and channels yeah
that that ron whatever perlman show
looks okay i'm gonna start watching that
he plays the judge and his son kills
himself and that son with the the show
this listen man i don't like
sitting there and watching tv but when
you go out at night and do comedy now
they don't do blows see when you do blow
you gotta find you get on stage
you do blow and that's your [ __ ]
night but now when you don't do blow
it's kind of interesting you come home
you get some coffee you get a notebook
you think of the jokes that bombed
you think of what didn't bomb you know
what i'm saying you watch a little tv
i'm so happy to hear you what's up
[ __ ] look at you nothing i'm high
it's different coming when you have when
you get listen in the old days as soon
as i got off that stage win place a show
whether i did good or bad didn't matter
thank you because i was going right to
that bathroom i didn't care if wheels
was watching and i was gonna do two
[ __ ] blasts of debt
he wouldn't watch you unless you went in
the ladies room and then i would go
right to that [ __ ] bar and get a
double or a shot yes that was it just to
get the blood going and then after the
alcohol came down i got in the car and i
got the [ __ ] out of there and went home
and finished the package so it's a
completely different adventure now i
don't even know how to act yeah
especially going to the store because
for years that was my mo when i went to
the store i was really scared does it
trigger you there at all because some
people can't they'll do their set and
they run out i agree i think it's a
[ __ ] thing well i went in there for
marin that was the first time i went in
there
he was like that in the beginning he got
better now did he but he was afraid to
come in yeah i hadn't been in there at
all and somebody like lee i got to shoot
at comedy stone a couple people like are
you concerned i'm like no well not only
were you shooting at the comedy store
they made you do fake coke right i'm an
adult you know like i'm a [ __ ] adult
yeah you're saying like
sorry i got a nut that's all right get
it it's clean it's clean i went from jiu
jitsu but i remember going there and i
got really sentimental yeah when i
walked in those are the two reasons i
went back to the store was walking
through there and knowing that i had so
much time invested yeah and i'm not
talking about [ __ ] time in the belly
room
or time [ __ ] around i'm talking about
sweat i hosted in that [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah and i put all that time fat baby
fat baby yeah
i went home and i had to do a
colonoscopy
and
you can't sleep after a certain point
you got to drink this [ __ ] vinegar
like too yeah and i drank the vinegar
and i started smoking pot and it's not
really vinegar it's some juice they give
you this [ __ ] your blood out or whatever
the [ __ ] and for some reason for years
marilyn martinez would torment me about
being there
we would talk about comics like like
that [ __ ] you were watching this weekend
yeah like if you came to me and said dog
i watched three pink panther movies with
what's her name just to show her real
[ __ ] comedy is i'd have no beef with
you
i'd say you showed her history yeah you
showed it but that shows
it's got no moments dawg nobody's gonna
remember that show in 30 years
nobody just this [ __ ] stupid
generation yeah but that's the reason
you don't need chinese food anymore you
have to watch you have to be able to
watch new things sometimes that's
garbage there is so much there is so
much [ __ ] that you need to watch if you
want to be in this business and that's
not one of them yeah that's not one of
them i'm on joey's okay that's not one
of them
if you want to do anything with comedy
you got to watch the great [ __ ]
comics and there is nobody who
translated more on film than peter
sellers and i hate [ __ ] english
people and at that time at that time i
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
why are they speaking like that what and
when i went to see those couple movies
and then i went back after i became a
comic
see i watched them and then i went back
after i became a comic and i shot [ __ ]
so you know exactly when they told them
cut you know exactly when they said cut
because they couldn't take it no more
like this [ __ ] cut we can't take
it you just destroyed the set like if
you ever see they always say when
christopher walken walks on the set it's
completely different you could have
everybody on the set when christopher
walken down and said do yourself a favor
put away the cell phone cause you're
about to learn something people like
even in rehearsal people clap like a 30
[ __ ] years you know it's 30 years you
cannot take that away from them well
what about um the guy in [ __ ] narco
the mexican guy who we were talking
about this past weekend he plays gotcho
louis louis yeah
yeah doing it [ __ ] how long he said
twenty-two
terrific i saw him on the second season
of miami vice
the opening episode when the colombians
go to new york he that's eight 1984 so
you do the [ __ ] math wow that's 31
[ __ ] years you know i was watching uh
el rey you ever watch l ray channel it's
robert rodriguez's channel he's got some
interesting stuff and he's got a lot of
kung fu stuff
you can see where him and tarantino
blend they like old school stuff yeah
they really went back listen
the cup volume kill bill volume one and
two they're not academy award winners in
my book but if i see tarantino i'll give
him a hug you know why because he's
watched every
bad martial art film i watched he's
watching references you know they could
reference it so that's what i was
telling leave that i'd watch those first
three peter seller movies that before
any of this [ __ ] you're watching any
other [ __ ] any of this nonsense that 902
with all black people in prison with the
lesbians i don't even know what the [ __ ]
you want oh orange is the new yeah i
like what the [ __ ] you're watching i
watched that one if you and that's what
happened i i i had tate being there and
marilyn martinez was a big time catholic
yeah big time catholic you used to
always brush my balls about watch being
there watch me and i couldn't sleep and
i had some weed and i smoked and i
watched being there and it just
took me that's dice's favorite movie i
mean it has never
a movie has never taken me like this
like that i broke down emotionally in
the living room like you do when you're
yeah nine and you're making your first
communion for the first time and you go
down there and everything's a joke for
me everything is a joke until i got that
wafer in my mouth
and i sat down and knelt down
god touched me i remember feeling
like you know that's why i hate going to
church sometimes because it's reality
for me when i go to church sometimes and
i sit in and i'm a little high and a 7
30 mask
and i'm not really ready to accept this
but i start looking at the 12 stations
of the cross
and by the time i get to him getting
picked up dog i break down that's what i
grew up in yeah that's what i [ __ ]
grew up in
so when i saw p now i'm watching a guy
lee that was my comedy idol like him you
jackie gleason and what's the dude a tit
would fall out in front of every show
the english guy
that's as good as it gets in my world
especially after you've done comedy
and you want and so now i'm looking at
this guy that i loved oh please now i
love this guy
that i looked at as one of the best
comedians of all time he don't do a
comedic thing in being there
not a comedic thing lee
like
if i go for drama shows sometimes it's
like a cop asking me questions
after three questions
even me being dramatic you're going to
get a howl out of it because the way i
say it what what do i know what the [ __ ]
you what you know
something i'll stutter and get a lot
most producers don't want that yeah and
they'll go joey we really love you for
the role but after the third line you
have this [ __ ] howling this is a tv
drama it's a tv drama
so peter sellers when you have you seen
being there yes when you watch it and
what's your name was good looking in
that movie um
yes
she was beautiful in that [ __ ] movie
when i watched that movie at five in the
[ __ ] morning
it just it just taught like i had to get
up smoke pot light a candle
you know
make breakfast no i couldn't even make
breakfast i remember saying when i get
back and sleep i'm calling the store for
spots
that was the reason why that's how much
that movie touched me because marilyn
so it was marin
and that movie how crazy just because
marilyn always referred that movie to me
once i saw that movie so you never
watched it when she was
telling you to watch
listen in 19 i get it from like i was
telling lee from 88 to
2006 i only watched what was important
to me right i didn't go out of my limb
because i didn't have time i was
snorting blow i was doing comedy if it
was something that motivated me i'm in a
hotel room and goodfellas design i watch
it i'm in a hotel room on the weekends
and [ __ ] philadelphia but
you know i watch gang land in a hotel do
i stay home and watch it when i'm home
on friday morning [ __ ] no but when i'm
in a hotel room i can't wait to finish
seven i can't wait to finish radio so i
get back to my hotel room either [ __ ]
sandwich and watch gang land and
remember here it starts at six so in new
york it starts at nine so it goes to
like three in the afternoon so i'm in
[ __ ] heaven but i got nothing to do
i'm in a [ __ ] hotel room in a strange
city i gotta get up go to the museum
which i'm not doing yeah or i could sit
here and watch gang land and find out
what black people are doing now ideas
don't hit the met
[ __ ] i did all that dumb [ __ ] imagine i
walked around for years you did it as a
feature act
when you're a headliner you don't have
[ __ ] time you have so much things on
your mind you have people paying money
to come see you that want to laugh when
i'm a feature in front of joe do you
think i gave a [ __ ] yeah who didn't come
i had 20 minutes to do i just go up
there and do stupidity but if you want
people to keep coming back you gotta get
up you gotta get up and give them some
love so i'm not if i'm [ __ ] around
all afternoon
with people eating hot dogs
by the time i get there at eight o'clock
i'm more haha hot out yeah i'm already
cha-cha-cha there's not a lot of ha-ha's
out there
so you go to the men get a little
culture i i made uh dice go
last year last summer me and his wife
got him to go it was pretty amazing to
watch him what is this [ __ ] because
i'll tell you why it's amazing
we didn't have a show that the same
reason why my wife has a great time with
me
because
where i come from you don't go to the
[ __ ] men no okay so when somebody
makes you go to the met at first you
fight it
but then you actually have a great time
yeah like my favorite place in new york
new york city
the [ __ ]
listen when new york sneezes all you
little [ __ ] catch a cold yeah
and the story
but my favorite place in new york is
smoking a joint going to museum and
natural history god forbid god forbid i
catch an egg roll before i walk in there
or two
god forbid i catch an egg roll by
mistake or two good sad bread hot dogs
or a good [ __ ] a good [ __ ] those
steaks on a stick that you put on the
gyro and eat it god forbid on the way in
i catch three or four of those
two three hours at the stack at the
museum of natural history they nobody
better than you with a walkman on stoned
to the [ __ ] gills and you get the the
thing and then you go out you just hit
the [ __ ] roots and you come back in
again that's my world
that's number one number two is going
deep into harlem getting a bag of dope
and getting some cuban food or some
black soul food or some barbecue and
going to a [ __ ] triple feature like a
clint eastwood triple feature for three
dollars wow listen anybody can go to
movies with white people go to movies
with black people
right then honestly this is 30 years ago
ladies and gentlemen i don't know how it
is now but i watched all those movies
that's an afternoon for me everything
else going to the beach yeah and all
that [ __ ] in new york i'm not going to
san janeiro feast when i go back there
yeah i don't like none of that [ __ ] man
i really like when i headline friday and
saturday i like to relax yeah i don't
want no drama hey hey let's do dinner do
dinner with your mother not this time
i'm by myself today if not i gotta talk
to you about the chicken what do you
think about the lettuce yeah and i'm
[ __ ] wearing myself out yeah i don't
want to wear myself i like i just got so
many [ __ ] [ __ ] i could see me
what's up lisa yeah no more this [ __ ] on
the weekends
we do the same we like the same things
[ __ ] going outside that's why you get a
girlfriend so you don't have to go
outside anymore good i'm going outside
my boyfriend cleaned my windows today
i'm going to go outside clearly in the
morning she's got to go out and greet
the day today
and
how can i talk to you at nine at two
o'clock you headed to the gym
you sat there for four hours looking
watching looking at what doing what how
can you sit in the house at nine in the
morning once the day opens up looking at
where do you go at nine in the morning
anywhere but in that [ __ ] house
really i can't listen
third thing i do is take a shower and
wash my [ __ ] so there's no
misunderstanding okay okay you ever get
up in your little bots and you're [ __ ]
up and at 11 o'clock you realize you
haven't taken a shower cause you're
gonna take a shower take a [ __ ]
shower it wakes you right the [ __ ] up
don't show up by me with [ __ ] curls
and that [ __ ] up
take a shower in the [ __ ] morning i
agree and it makes it brightens
everything and once you take a shower
it's like your mind your body why do
they take a shower let me go outside and
see what's cracking
and you go outside and you look and you
get to man you thank the lord for giving
you another [ __ ] day look at what
everyone who's ever running [ __ ] on the
sun thank you for turning it on another
day somebody paid the bill for the sun
somebody pay the light bill they paid
the light bill something and by doing
that now you're like well i got to do
something
well maybe i don't have to go exercise
nobody says you got to go exercise who
am i jacqueline for a walk
roll that number that same joint you
smoked on your balcony when was the last
time you smoked a joint just went for a
walk to think i have ideas
uh-oh you don't
i've been telling you for 10 [ __ ]
years smoke a little joint go for a
[ __ ] walk see what happens to you
see what happens to you i live next to
our popeyes and the wiener schnitzel
where am i going to walk oh popeye's a
weaner spiritual but if you notice next
to the [ __ ] popeyes is a yoga studio
that's offering a free week for free i
can't do that
why not how many classes am i going to
sign up it's better it's a free week
you're going there like a jew you're
going there for a week and on the fifth
delay you run the [ __ ] out i hurt my
wrist i'm on disability i shouldn't have
been here anyway i'm doing kettlebells
jiu-jitsu the gym that's it
that [ __ ] you're doing at 24-hour that
don't count no more yes it does walking
up and down that don't that don't do
nothing to you no more it does it
doesn't you're better beyond that you're
way beyond that now you can't a year
he's been on the elliptical like a
moment a year that said it wore off
it's lying to you the things in your
hands are lying alignment
i don't know if that's accurate all
right i'm telling you right now
tomorrow you got kettlebells john bud
said you're going to jiu jitsu wednesday
night with him it's going to be nice and
take care how am i going to go wednesday
night we were walking we got no podcast
wednesday night so we got no podcast see
that he just gave you the night off
and i get to go get choked and get shoes
you get beat up what the [ __ ] what's
better than that who's better than you
27 years old you got the world by the
balls then omanplata is scary that's
right it's all scary it's a crazy move
where like they flip you over and like
you have to have your arm with their
legs and it's so exciting i never doing
knee balls i was upside down with my
[ __ ] wide open a flag would have been
flying by and he got shot by a gun he
would have flown right into my [ __ ]
[ __ ] just not [ __ ] magneto you
know perfect
just
just don't make it just that magneto
purpose someone needs to to illustrate
that did you see someone did a cartoon
of when ralphie was on no and i look
like the like hitler's drawings of jews
what oh like the guy who drew me
made it looks like i'm like the drawings
that hitler did of the jews
it's [ __ ] hysterical
i don't know if i ever saw the drawings
that hitler did not hitler did but the
the nazis did all that yeah i didn't
know him out of drawing school actually
hitler wasn't he's making little stick
pictures he's an artist like half these
momos weren't artists
he wasn't bad everybody wants to be an
audience well he wasn't bad knowing
defending hitler he thinks he's saying
they should have let him in art school
if they let him in art school he
wouldn't have killed all the jews he
would have been a prick anyway he would
have done something that cox said yeah
he would have figured something out yeah
hitler had a [ __ ] plan since they
were so what they're saying if he would
have got to art school
and if i would have got the prison i
wouldn't have kidnapped ken bella look
at it
you're saying [ __ ] difference i guess
i don't know i don't know if anyone's
saying it i said it when i found out
that he didn't get into art school he
tried to get in twice
maybe if he was an artist he wouldn't so
that's what i'm saying so you're saying
he's an artist if he was a better
audience if he was a better artist he
would have gotten to the drawing school
maybe he should have been born today
where they give everybody a ribbon so he
felt good about himself
too bad he was born in a day where you
gotta be good or you know he's a [ __ ]
artist hold on let me throw up let me
know
let me throw a piece of [ __ ] peanut
butter on that white wall boom i'm a
[ __ ] artist and there's always three
jerk-offs that are sitting there
going oh my god that's bro
whatever it's just a different society
to get into now even comedians their
artist all of a sudden i'm a [ __ ]
comedian please i don't know about no
artistry i try to tell stories at hash
ways deli that's my university these
guys go to juilliard they're walking
around half [ __ ] i learned how to do
comedy 101 at hash ways deli on the bus
that's right you know what the [ __ ]
i'm gonna go to the [ __ ] improv
olympic and jump around with those
[ __ ] moments please
anything to see yeah hold on i'm a
lizard
hold on here i am i'm a lizard i just
right downstairs little [ __ ] lizard
ran for me you don't like lizards yeah
dog says i'm a new york city kid let me
tell you something when i was a kid i
used to live in the city and i would go
to miami in the summers and they had
tons of lizards and the first week i
couldn't sleep no just knowing that
lizards could come in my [ __ ] window
i would have a heart you've seen you saw
dead bodies and lizards scare you that's
different that's different they're dead
they can't crawl yeah while you're
sleeping that's only an amc and this
[ __ ] generation sits there and
watches a bunch of idiots walking around
[ __ ] dead walking dead
my brother tommy watches marathons it's
crazy investors are people who dress up
and go down the jersey shore and walk
around like they have that no listen the
best thing you could do with those
people is get a machine gun and spray
them while you're just spraying them and
do them a favor well you have dead
already you're walking around playing a
tv show that shoots in atlanta [ __ ]
like a momo i've done listen i don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on with
society i was just a mess i was in the
office before and i could hear the
scientology movie
oh it was great and the first thing i'm
thinking about in the back of my mind
was
let's be honest with ourselves i haven't
heard one [ __ ] black voice or mexican
in this this is a white [ __ ]
absolutely that you would join this [ __ ]
first of all they blackmail you there's
no way about it
isn't will smith one of them yeah but he
don't count no [ __ ] yeah he's
supposedly tom cruise yeah but i think
they got him later like we're
i'm serious like i got him they got him
recently and that's why though him and
his wife are breaking up she went in
there and said she sucked a thousand
black [ __ ] they told him he went
[ __ ] bananas he takes it in the ass
yeah you know they both had both of them
have allegations dr chick i remember
eddie he's a lesbian right she's a
lesbian eddie griffin's saying that they
he she was dying at the store yeah and
that she used to hang out the store
selling credit cards or boosting cards
or whatever the [ __ ] it is but once she
got with will smith she cut all that
communication oh yeah or something
[ __ ] she was a little bit of a hood
rat somebody's crazy yeah and then uh
but now like they're they're talking
about oh we're in an open relationship
she's going to pull more than him she's
going to get more [ __ ] and dick than
she knows
absolutely she [ __ ] jennifer lopez's
husband that's how the whole thing
started
was walking around he could get anything
no no not like her will smith supposedly
the word on the street was he was
[ __ ] the butler on the show on him in
the fall no the old guy and that's why i
like hampton the show i swear to god
listen let me tell you something
when i first came through this town i
got sacked west philly i got sat down by
two black people who read me the riot
act of my beliefs
the problem with the difference between
the white community and the black
community is the white community will
give you up the black community listen
the black community has known for 30
years that eddie murphy is gay now this
conversation we're having yeah does not
change how i feel about any murphy or
anything i'm just telling you to hear
say i've had i know two police officers
that have said that that second time
they caught him with the transvestite in
the car that was the second time he got
caught the one time it got publicized
they didn't go down there anymore
you know i hear these stories about him
going back to la in long island before
santa live that he has allegations of
being gay again it does not affect how i
feel about him or his comedy i don't
care whether you're gay you're not gay
it's the guys that now let me tell you
something that i noticed
if you told me
18 years ago i mean eddie murphy was gay
i'd punch in the face
once i saw him at the store you knew i
knew yeah me too didn't mean anything to
me again doesn't mean a thing to me and
then i had a friend at the best damn
sports show and she was blacker than
black and she liked me we used to talk
all the time and one day i asked her and
she just opened the valve up
and told cause she was older she was
you know 58 and she was like a wardrobe
chick and she was in that clique with
quincy jones and you know and also she
opened the vow and just told me about
you didn't know about eddie murphy oh my
god and then
banks
what's the crazy black guy that used to
hang out at the store with the drink
jiggling it all the time he said he was
richard pryor's manager david banks got
arrested souls
banks that's my boy right there he just
passed away right
yeah okay so david banks is up there one
night he used to talk shitley
lisa now what eleanor was [ __ ]
everybody
mitch is [ __ ] everybody that was his
was he really richard pry's manager no
he wasn't his manager he was a writer
producer
uh and he worked for everybody you could
google him you could watch him at the
roast
uh i think i believe it was a paul
mooney roast back oh no it was a prior
roast back in the day and paul mooney
and david banks and david banks rips
everybody including mooney which he
always hits on mooney he
in the green room in the main room he
goes he would say everybody mitchell is
[ __ ] everybody and then he goes uh
even paul moody he had his brazier on
and he cried the whole time
and paul mooney hey [ __ ] and
he'd come right he'd stay right in front
of him right and they fight and they
were so funny together guys i wish you
could see this this is real black
america no you can google it this is
[ __ ] awesome
i'm up there one night i don't know
nothing about nothing
i'm a [ __ ] dummy comic just
sitting for me waiting for my midnight
spot i'd go at nine that's all i had was
yeah
guys when i tell you that's all i was
like richard pryor in office and the
gentleman that's all i have
if the comedy store the doors open at
nine i was there at 10. yeah 9 30
waiting for a fallout you never yeah
dave look at him look how young
he's really young
david
you know most people know richard as a
comedian and an actor and so and that
ain't even how he started he started as
an athlete
he was pretty fast in me too oh yeah he
was nothing he was no boxer you can see
that he wouldn't know about you
but he used to get down on baseball and
with his usual style how you see how he
can rap i remembered i was with him man
that's
how of dodgers when they had the annual
tryout for this you know spring training
and all the ball players came out on the
field they had this long socks the
spikes richard fell out on the field
trying out for the team head on some hip
huggers
sanrimo boots
big apple hat cocktails
you know the man came out on the field
and said what do you want out here you
see i came out to the ball yard baby to
try for the team
he said what position can you play he
said i can handle them all you say you
mean you can play all positions in
baseball you said yeah i didn't already
told you man what you keep asking me for
some man said well i'ma ask him two or
three questions and i'll shoot him on to
the exit gate so you see you can play
all positions in baseball right he said
tell me can you play third base he said
i'd turn a hot corner cool
he said can you play shortstop he said i
pick it like pepper you know pepper's
hot
he said can you play second base he said
in and out the whole all day can't drink
don't miss
you say can you play first base he said
when i'm on the sack you can't throw a
bad man
he said can you play center field he
said covered like the morning dew you
know that's all over
he said can you catch he said in the
crouch throw bb's at second base weighs
high don't miss
you say can you run he said a roadrunner
comes second
he said can you bet he said inside my
pitch down the middle all day outside
over the fence ken pole
he said can you pitch he said he's been
in the stretch yet
he said what's your name man he said
sweet chocolate brown is my name shine
up with dewdrop griffin go live
man say you too tough man he said tell
you what you get on out in the left
field he said what he said you get out
in the left field he said which way is
that man
who's the white dude clapping
uh i don't know that's crazy but he did
roast everybody on the panel too well he
always used to be drinking david yeah he
always had that little drink and he'd
shake his hand and i always tell this
story i'm out there
and he comes up to me and it's
eddie murphy
paul mooney
arsenio hall
and the singer from
the black good looking singer from
the new edition
bobby brown no that's the wrong group
uh yeah i know i could see his face
ralph you used to
know i mean
he used to come up there with eddie
murphy
yes and they're standing by the comedy
store sign outside talking it's a slow
night wednesday night
30 people in the original room
i'm standing there talking to somebody
david banks walks out and what's up
playing nothing he looks up he sees
those four black guys standing
he's like watch this and he walks over
and goes what are you [ __ ] gonna do
the queen's accommodator
right to their faces and they just
walked away
right to their [ __ ] faces like
nothing ever happened
he would he would rip people and shreds
rip all those black guys apart i
remember him torture moon they were
afraid of him
because he would just talk [ __ ] like he
didn't stop i did not know i always
thought he would and then i i had a have
a richard pryor book at the house
and he's in the books sitting next to
richard at the comedy store yeah he's
done a lot he's in mooney's book a lot
he's in um richard's book david i mean
they make reference to him but he was
around he did everything for him he was
funny man
i miss paul mooney at that store me too
i haven't seen myself in the back yeah
i've been having a great [ __ ] time at
this though dude you killed the other
night saturday night
and last night i ate a big [ __ ] dick
oh i ate a dick
is she i haven't seen her in a long time
oh my god talking about getting pregnant
and how she used to just give him a hand
job
and then when he comes she'd sit on him
and wiggle like a like oh miley cyrus
and then she doesn't the wrecking ball
uh she'll have to flip off backwards and
make sure the [ __ ] dripped into a [ __ ]
she's standing on her head to get it oh
my god she was saying some wild [ __ ]
that you know the reason why she decided
to get pregnant wasn't because she was
old was it because i was getting old it
was because
she pregnant i wasn't getting as wet as
i was when i was 20. my [ __ ] was drying
up she goes when i was 20 i'd feel my
[ __ ] at work and if i took my fingers
out and threw up the peace sign there'd
be a string in between them i mean she
was saying
and i went up there and [ __ ] tried to
follow her and just died
i would get them and lose them get them
and lose them and it was just it was
okay it was salami was there salami came
down it was okay
it's just the comedy store the comedy
story that's how the comedy story it's
just the way the o.r is i ate it in the
main room late night saturday
ate it
it made i was all over the place it was
fun though it was saturday night
saturday late show i don't know what the
[ __ ] everybody killed
it was a great show killed bill burr i
was telling you today it was something
that
bill burr is getting funnier and funnier
because he's alrighty yeah he's getting
so insightful he was talking about his
wife not having sex with him oh that was
being mad at how he's a he feels like a
relief a relief picture just just [ __ ]
that you don't want to think of
and it's so entertaining
for a guy like me to go up there neil
brennan was killing me yeah yeah yeah
yeah grants was killing me i love to go
watch comedy and [ __ ] laugh from my
heart yeah i really want to laugh when i
go up there i really want to [ __ ]
laugh that's why i miss andrew i miss
andrew in more ways than one up there
because andrew
a lot of people avoided andrew because
he's real yeah and i like that about
andrew i learned a lot from andrew oh my
god
andrew inspired me to get on stage
watching him andrew taught me how to act
yeah with one short conversation
do the audition backwards
oh you know who says that type of [ __ ]
andrew because he has balls of steel
aren't you
yeah he told me that when he booked the
show on nbc
he made sure the guy kept the camera
rolling and it was the [ __ ] he was doing
in between that got me the job
he asked michael mann
so tell the [ __ ] idiot to keep the
camera moving and [ __ ] around
let the guy know you're a personality
you're not there really i'll never
forget the speech he had with me yeah
that was christ
he was going to rascals and it was too
late he was already [ __ ] sold out and
they called him that friday like that
thursday night dice having an education
talking to dice is four years like i
mooched on to andrew
and i didn't have to ask him he knew
what i wanted to hear yeah after every
set when he'd seen me in doubt
you know andrew had been there there's
something different about a [ __ ]
jerk-off yeah and there's something
different about somebody who's paid
their dues
you know you know when somebody's paying
that dude yeah i know when somebody's
faking the funk now it's just very
simple so many to sell you when
somebody's friend they're calling you
and telling y'all oh my god and you know
it you know it because i know what it's
like i know what it's like to do four
sets i know what it's like to do four
sets and bomb at three of them yeah and
i know how you're supposed to act and
feel you know that last bailout is the
store but [ __ ] you gotta follow
somebody that jesus christ i'm gonna get
four beatens tonight yeah you know and
then yeah and you bump it you know i was
telling the league ten years ago
like as of 2006 i was one of those guys
that got 20 phone calls a day
of people telling me like look i'm doing
this i'm doing that what the [ __ ] is
going on
and you're like listen you know and i
would ask them simple questions where
were you last night well i stayed in
last night because me and my friend are
writing the script well listen
that script suck my dick you and your
[ __ ] script yeah you could write the
script after you go to the coffee shop
and sign up to do a set that's right
that's why you're calmly slipping you
know i went out last night to the store
to die
you know because i'm taping a dvd in
vegas oh great so i want to be sharp too
i can't do every [ __ ] night but if i
do every other night and right in
between at least i can bring something
up to the stage and i could be prep
friday i go to the ice house and then
next week i got three or four more shows
before i have to tape on friday night so
i'll be [ __ ] ready you know what i'm
saying like yep this is what you do you
know
i lived here long enough where to get
good at comedy and lee we've been
talking about this for three weeks you
have to fall in love with [ __ ] oh yeah
like you really have to be good at
anything whether it's parachute jumping
you got to do it as much as you [ __ ]
can you know as much as you can when
last night i had a show and they
canceled it and i have been doing so
many sets this week and bombing at most
of them that i literally was like thank
god because i don't think i could take
another take another [ __ ] bombing
that's how fast i can't take another
bite and i mean my boyfriend we made
tacos and we just chilled out we were
just like screw it and then he washed my
windows this morning you don't get any
better than that
it's not a metaphor that's a real thing
you're touring a lot
uh yeah i'm going out a lot i mean not
touring someone i mean just doing spots
like when i'm in la i do as many spots
so you do the second spot before andrew
i do
20 to 30. it depends on how andrew feels
andrew's really taking good care of you
he's
unbelievable like a four-year degree
yeah you can't [ __ ] believe it
it's the best schooling ever and his
crowd is not accepting of oh who's this
girl you know like they're like
you know and they always try to talk at
you when you come out like who the [ __ ]
does she think she is you got to win
them over you got like only a few
seconds to do it and it's been he's like
just get out there just punch them in
the face just keep punching them just
keep hitting them and that's what i do
and it's great and it's weird like when
i go in front of a regular clown i'm
like how come they haven't thrown
anything at me yet you know like you
have to transition so it's like learning
so much i did that dirty at 12 30. that
crowd was so polite
but they were terrific it's crazy how
polite they are yeah they don't laugh at
real dirty stuff
uh they freeze up a little bit on you
you know yeah they they like the racism
i gotta be honest there was because it
was like a
hatch of black people over here the
mexicans were over here the white people
were in the frog i was like whoa this is
segregated it's like philadelphia i feel
like i'm home
and they just went crazy they loved like
stupid [ __ ] like that he was putting a
nice thing together at the same time
yeah there were asians i mean it was it
was really awesome he's killing it yeah
i love that guy that runs in mike
i like when people put labor into comedy
yep and it comes back so many people
give up after three weeks so many people
that have no vision give up like they
get a comedy room and nobody came
well that seventh week
just that seventh week could have been
the week where some chick with a big
mouth comes in
has a good time somebody [ __ ] her in
the hallway and she goes and tells
everybody how cool that place is
because it's all about for it to be cool
to go down and have a good time and
giggle and have a scene somebody sells
ecstasy somebody wears a sinatra hat
right somebody's got to have a hat on
like goatee and suspenders to be oh my
god
you look so cute yeah
you know a picture with hitler on a
horse with a gun in his hand
something else there's drawings in his
hand what about ari you guys are going
to film him in the second season now
yeah coming up ari what
his show what's happening now oh great
wait what is it called
what's happening now
this is not happening
and that started off as a free show oh
my god yeah it was just something fun he
was doing uh at the store or wherever he
would do it everywhere
that's right i did it at the improv
twice so in the back with mark maron i
did it the first time eric is that right
yep yeah in the back for no money no
booze yep and then they moved into the
big room yeah then they shot it for the
internet and they shot it from comedy
central it's been an amazing run it
really happened
yeah
i got to do it with greg fitzsimmons
that was great christmas stories because
he's so sick irish i love him i love him
do you like it i was just on his podcast
outstanding and he has crazy stories
about like just silly things growing up
irish i don't know if other people are
allowed to but like
you know your aunts and uncles were
allowed to hit us you know what i mean
and so he talks about this beating that
his one of his cousins got from not
their parents somebody else's parents
and everybody was fine with it and he
just had to sit in the room with the
coats bleeding
how much has time changed in 30 years
that there was a time when a neighbor
could kick in the ass god damn right and
now your parents aren't even allowed to
touch you nothing yep it's the craziest
i say i blame the internet social media
because if you hit a kid today they'll
take a picture and put it right on
instagram daddy hit me you know and then
they get 50 likes and dad goes to jail i
don't get it
we couldn't do that but do they not
listen to the parents
side if they do call the kids and the
kids call the cops do they not listen to
the parents no first of all i'm the
kid's parent you should not even be here
exactly let me tell you what happened
yeah i was sitting at the table he
disrespected me i drew a glass of milk
in his [ __ ] face and sent him to his
[ __ ] room what's wrong with that i'm
not hearing anything weird at this point
except for milk we probably wouldn't
have milk at dinner but but you know
what i'm saying are you throwing the
glass too or just the milk no just tell
them you know whatever i mean of course
when you raise a child there's a way to
raise a child
i'm not saying beat him with a [ __ ]
stick i only got like i hit a couple
times like i got spanked a few times but
like the threat of it when they spank it
they put your right knee right no i
don't even think it was up with the knee
but then after the first time right and
your parents threatened with that you
were scared and you stayed in line
correct yeah right oh yeah my mom was
super strict yes it's uh it's weird
seeing kids like who are like like
that's the one thing i never bought
about the sopranos the way that his kids
acted
i don't think that would have happened
he no but he did he went with her he
went on the spot don't do that let them
you know let's be this way let's nurture
him and they change it no hitting the
kids things like that he wanted to she
wouldn't let him like it never makes
sense to me when a kid goes like in a
show like a parent asks a kid to do
something like he's like oh dad that's
like i wouldn't i no the the thought of
it now and i'm i haven't lived at home
for over nine years still makes me look
i feel i feel it would feel weird to do
that i'd lose my teeth
when you i mean my mom would smack the
[ __ ] out of it i got my niece i have a
new roommate my niece is living with me
23. i met her yeah i met her at the
store last night please
she's telling me because she grew up
like that you know let's talk about our
feelings
spoil
you know i want to express myself yeah
yeah i live in a studio expression i'm
not sharing anything while you're
scrubbing the [ __ ] sink with a
toothbrush i don't clean up after
herself i don't know what happened to
this god damn [ __ ]
that i never thought my mom lifting a
hand to me growing up was abuse at all
yeah
i could tell you that i deserved
everything i got from her
me too i was never hit wrongfully when
my stepfather came into the picture he
switched it up
when one got out of jail married my mom
and moved in with us
he she wasn't hitting me he was getting
notebooks
and making me just sit there and write
like if there was a problem at the house
that's it no just sit there all right
right what lines
i will not lie to my mother i will not
lie to my mother i will not lie to them
wow i don't think school one time i had
to write him in the front in english and
they're back in spanish you know
i mean that means i won't [ __ ] argue
with it
like and i would sit there and if i did
something really bad he would take the
chair away and i'd have to kneel on two
beans
okay that sounds better but he didn't
believe so but this was three or four
days of coming home from school at three
and riding until 10 o'clock
eat dinner you shower but the whole
other time you're just writing [ __ ]
i don't have kids
but like i could
like i could see like it's like a little
tap on the head or maybe like a spank
but when it gets back when it goes past
that i think i mean i don't know but i i
see you guys
how sweet you are you are with mercy
yeah but she's also going to be 13 one
day and there has to be somebody who's
firm and it has to be somebody who could
talk to her yeah but what the biggest
lesson listen my mom would blab this was
th this was the mo in my house i did
something
my mom would have a thousand things on
my mind [ __ ] come over and blast me
and yell at me and ask me why i did it
and then anybody who came by my mom
would explain to him [ __ ] him
this is what this [ __ ] did yeah
i'll [ __ ] kill you you ever do
something like that again money here
wait yeah somebody would go to nora for
the love of christ and she'd say [ __ ]
that [ __ ] let him cry and i'd
usually be holding a towel with blood
from my lip my mom didn't [ __ ] around
jack but i got it she didn't want it she
was raising a man yeah and she
understood that at some age this
[ __ ] is gonna test you in her
mind
she didn't even want to be tested yeah
like that was not going to happen in her
world
my mom knew the importance of her
having a presence over me
you understand and i'm and i'm telling
you she spoiled me and there was things
she did but when it was time to get down
we got down yeah she [ __ ] got down
yeah towards the end i could tell that
she wasn't doing me no favors you know
when her i would do [ __ ] and then my dad
would call me on it she would stick up
for me yeah and i'd be proud because she
stuck up for me but oh years later i'm
not proud because she ruined her
relationship with him
to lie but she was like one she was like
paulie galteria's mother
oh my god you know
you know like you know
where where you know it's like your kid
doesn't do nothing wrong right you know
i didn't want that i don't want my wife
to be like that with mercy
kids [ __ ] up bro kids [ __ ] up you got to
call their attention and as a a single
mom
you got to watch your boys like a
[ __ ] animal yeah and there's going to
come a day when that boy is 14. he's
going to be cute and that day is not the
day you're gonna push him or punish him
or make him right that's that you gotta
steamroll that [ __ ] a busted
head break his computer cuts
and that [ __ ] will never happen again
that's a beating everybody remembers but
do you think it has to be the mom like
is it do you think a single mom he's
saying well no but even even with him
because i mean everything in my world it
was my listen my mom was not gonna my
mom was
i don't think juan ever raised his hand
to me i know juan and i got into heated
arguments i know juan was bitched in my
mom and my mom would tell him to [ __ ]
off
my mom was always the aggressor i told
the story
my mom was hitting me and i put my hand
up
and she [ __ ] freaked and went and got
a bounty roll and lit it on fire and
said she's going to burn my hand because
when you hit your mom or your hands are
going to stick out of the way
you have no idea dog
you have no [ __ ] idea what what you
know she went and got a bounty rose she
went and got me at my friend's house and
started yelling in spanish my mom was no
joke there was jokes at my house but
there was a line with no and this whole
beef was about making a bed
like you're making a bed and i'm like
i'm not making the [ __ ] bed okay
don't miss the bed
do what you need to do
i'm gonna
i dare you not to make the bed that's
that's it i'll give you 50 bucks not the
baby
yeah and i went to the [ __ ] pool
party and i could hear her at the pujo
san antonio
oh whole song and i could hear that look
getting louder and louder i'm in the
pool with 18 people who don't know what
spanish is
because of my sport
yeah i swear to god i'm like what and
also she came to the fence and she
started hitting it with a stick you know
the stick from a broom please she
started hitting the fence and they're
like who is that lady i'm like i have no
[ __ ] idea
she's she could hear me going no idea
and i went out the back and she saw me
and i'll never forget that was one of
the last good beatings she gave me
because she chased me all the way home
with the stick i love her and she was
yelling and screaming in spanish and
then she crossed the street and finally
i ran her and i got home and then she
came home get down here make that
[ __ ] bed and then we got into the
city and she went to smack me and i
blocked
oh now you know after a while your moms
get so tired that they they just want to
hit you for making them
tired you know what i'm saying like ah
you're [ __ ] and that's when she
put the [ __ ] paper towel and the
paper she's hit me with the paper towel
on fire and chunks are falling on the
carpet yeah i'm like oh hitting me and
stepping on the carpeting at the same
time it was a tremendous [ __ ] scene
until this day i'm telling you
that i understood because someday
mercy is going to say something like
that to me and i got to make a point
yeah i got to make a point maybe leave
the bounty out of it yeah i ain't
[ __ ] around here exactly you know i
ain't [ __ ] around here that's what
she you know
there was just something about her
demeanor you know i you said something
that really bothers me because it
bothers me because it's true well the
worst thing i did when i was a child
was the [ __ ] with no time to come in
oh my mother raised me with no curfew
that's not good
that is crazy yeah we had a few that's
not good that's not good and when you
hear it from other people it sounds so
bad
when you hear white people going yeah
his parents used to let him stay out all
night when he was a kid
no you're like what are you [ __ ]
crazy
let me cause my mom was a single mom
with 10 kids
and she would go to sleep and then we
would sneak out we would come in at the
appropriate time like whatever time she
sat and then when she would go to sleep
she was a heavy sleeper we were just my
parents
i don't know if this was a reason
because it was like this my entire life
but my front door had a bell on it
like the door into the garage yeah
but we did have another door which we
could use i never did that i don't know
i go out the basement i don't think
when i got a car i don't think i had a
curfew no i did because when you were 16
you couldn't be out past midnight
driving so it's kind of unfortunate i
could say things at this table right now
the normal things that i could say
that if i think of mercy doing them i
want to cry no yeah yeah
simple things i did as a you know what
that is to walk from 48th street to 29th
street
at 12 30 at night after a movie
especially back then especially in the
70s with another person new york was a
different place i don't know this was
north park this was university
oh wow which is still it's the mouth to
new york city hoboken union city she had
the bar on 29th street she let me walk
up bergen line which is sunset so she
pretty much let me go from duke's
restaurant
mm-hmm to
maybe highland
it was one way it was called burger lion
avenue i mean we did that though today
we like you're being sensitive you're
like i would never let my daughter do
that i can't see but but it and like my
brother bobby his his son is 14. he they
moved to the suburbs it's all white kids
right
brandon loves basketball god love him he
plays he's like these kids stink yes
we're beating everybody so we're going
to south philly so he figured out he
didn't ask his father who grew up in
south philly could take him to any
ball park and right across the street
from my mother's house you can play
everybody projects are on the other side
of the playground so you can play
whomever you want you know we all kind
of hang out in the playground and play
he didn't say nothing he got on a bus
and went from the suburbs down into the
city not my mom's neighborhood somebody
another neighborhood like you can't do
that you can't you know he could have
gotten beat up bad he could have gotten
robbed could have gotten killed whatever
crazy [ __ ] happens at that you know
right where pats and genos are he went
there and played in that playground
those kids now how far has he live from
there uh it's about a 20-minute car ride
so they took the bus how old is he 14. i
did it all the time we did it but for
some reason me and bobby and bobby he
got sensitive he punished him
he was like i don't want you doing that
brother i'm sorry now i know it's hard
to imagine but if you had a boy would it
be different
he is a boy no i'm saying oh no no no no
no i want him to push the envelope a
little bit listen you want your child to
push the envelope a little bit yeah you
the only way to listen the only way to
lift 500 pounds is to lift 500 pounds
and see where you're at and go you know
what i'll try it again next week i'll
try it again
it's it's scary
at six
at five and six i was already crossing
the street
to go to whatever supermarket boost
bounds where the [ __ ] it was the jew
supermarket when i was a kid it was on
88th street and broadway
she begged me not to cross broadway
begged me yeah come on man i'm crossing
bro nothing
straight
i crossed everywhere
you know
i love hot dogs
listen listen if there's a hot dog on
the other side of the boulevard they
don't understand the worst thing about
being on a diet
yeah you could still eat two hot dogs or
two buns and that's it put a little
sauerkraut but when you're a fat [ __ ]
and you go down in
you don't even tell your friends you
could devour eight of those
and yeah and even if you know that
there's another guy that has the same
you know eight on the street i can just
do one after another before
to my daughter's eyes i could eat seven
[ __ ] sad breads
if you left me if i smoked dope you go
to a cyber store that's got good
sauerkraut good ideas
and i'll mix and match
i'll open up with two mustard and
sauerkrauts if they're good right there
opening it up throw me two more with
chilies
let's see what we got i might get five
of them and one of them is bad now i'm
stuck with four [ __ ] bad hot dogs
right because that's the point now this
is this is the street this isn't like a
place for the table you're just like no
why do you buy a hot dog anybody can
make oscar my hot dogs at the house when
you invest in someone you look something
in the angle how the hot dogs today and
he goes they're [ __ ] off the chain i
just put them in their nice cigarettes
see let's open up with two with
sauerkraut a little bit of mustard brown
please extra bacteria let me get a
coconut let me get a coconut can bam you
open up with two and after you wipe your
fingers with that hot dog still in your
mouth
as you chew it you go let me get two
more
with onions right let's see how the
onions are let's see what happened there
once you inhale those two
once those two onion ones come at you
those red new york onions
it's over then you tell them let me get
another can of the coke
and let me get two more this one give me
one chili give me one chili with raw
onions and give me one with raw onions
and mustard so now you had the whole
spectrum no chips in there no chips
chips are for amateurs
when that chinese kid eats 200 hot dogs
you see him eating chips [ __ ] no he eats
hot dogs there's no chips that's my
amateur is that today yeah labor day
right
then right there you're lurking you've
already had six of them you know your
mom is making meatloaf with mashed
potatoes the way you like it you're
gonna have to smoke another joint but
you say [ __ ] it i'm not coming up to
this name before whop dog oh no my sport
for war
what do you want on that one [ __ ] it
it's your choice
draw the dice that beat [ __ ]
i could inhale seven street hot dogs in
new york when i was running in new york
and now dude i got no shame to tell
somebody
anyway the [ __ ] point of the story
too when i walk away all right good for
you two and i'll walk away the point of
the story is when i was a kid and i
first came from cuba i thought that hot
dogs would make you a better american
wow
they lie to you over there don't they no
i just don't this was this was an
assumption that i made i thought that if
you ate pizza hamburgers it's american
hot dogs it was the quickest way to
become an american don't let me tell you
what happened when i discovered spam and
[ __ ] dad used to make me spam an eggs
on a hot plate when i discovered spam as
a kid white people at somebody's house i
was like oh this is this is a nation
america he wouldn't make it at my
mother's house she'd kick them out i
went to a friend's house and they made
spam sliced thin
fried with sauerkraut on that with
sauerkraut with spinach with diced
little onions and
garlic oh it was fancy oh my god [ __ ]
spam with spinach when i was a kid i
thought i was gonna be popeye cause who
the [ __ ] eats spinach by that like
popeye you gotta be a jerk off to eat a
can of spinach but with spam [ __ ] it i
meant kill it oh my god anyway the point
being oh [ __ ]
oh my god
it's monday
the 7th it's a holiday today in cuba
i have some good [ __ ] reefer
yes it was
anyway the the thing why i'm disturbed
at this whole hot dog story
is because my daughter loves hot dogs oh
and i gotta switch them up on it with
the turkey ones which i [ __ ] hate but
my wife says it's better what hot dog
story i don't [ __ ] know but i give
oscar maya the angus beef ones right i
chop them up nice she likes those and i
make her mac and cheese straight up well
and she loves [ __ ] man now she loves
hot dogs because it's
hereditary she don't even know about
america whatever the [ __ ] it stands for
right but she likes [ __ ] hot dogs so
when i was a kid i took a [ __ ]
beating for hot dogs
that's how much i like hot dogs and it
was like a six block walk i was five
years old this is what petrifies me
about mercy
these are the things that keep me up at
night
okay this this [ __ ] hummus these are
the things that i can't sleep at night
you understand me how he could watch 10
episodes on the [ __ ]
tv
not that she eats hummus that at the age
of six when you're how old are you when
you're in kindergarten what's the
natural
six or seven right five or six if you
were to kindergarten and you're seven
you're a dumb [ __ ] right that means you
can't even put blocks together you
should
that means you got everything uh four or
five when i was five yeah
um i went to school with ps166 or for
amsterdam and the street after that but
if you went three more streets there was
central park yeah it was like [ __ ]
ten blocks over i'm five years old guys
i'm a house a block away from 205 west
88 this is 89th street in the middle
and up the block and a half there was a
hot dog guy
so i would go get hot dogs i was five
and my mom would give me like five bucks
and i'd go eat hot dogs and she'd tell
me how many [ __ ] hot dogs are you
gonna eat in a [ __ ] day and one day
the school shut it down on me
you can't leave the premises i was five
walking off the reservation where'd you
get the money my mom oh wow i was
[ __ ] five walking off the reservation
like school lunch that's beneath me
like you have to sit like a candy
cigarette behind your ears no
do you think that mercy could walk off
the premises no not now they won't let
it do it now no they they won't do that
now it's all protected here's what i'm
[ __ ] saying here's my point guys
why would you worry about it because now
it's because oh my god
she wants to every time i see her she's
zoomed by the [ __ ]
listen five or six you should not be
walking the streets of new york city for
a [ __ ] hot dog as a kid and in those
days no other kids had five nobody gave
a [ __ ] no nobody other kid like i would
[ __ ] go to the bar
and i would bartend when i was five i
would go to the bar and put ice in the
thing i would put the beers stock the
beers and i would clean the bathroom and
she'd throw a 20 on me a 20 in 1968.
it's 50 [ __ ] bucks
so i would break half of it go to the
store i remember my big thing in those
days
i used to [ __ ] the guy up at the store
i used to give him a toy no
a five dollar bill and he used to give
me 25 quarters
why
what did it even make sense now how many
callers in the final bill
20. wait yeah money okay why would he
give you five i don't know one time i
went and then he gave me 25 quarters and
it was like i didn't tell nobody
i found the way they make money i'm
gonna go into everything give me five
hours and [ __ ] them up tell them i want
quarters
he was like a puerto rican to do
something every day give me like an
extra two quarters 50 cents i would
[ __ ] you've been doing this since you
were five yes dog this is in my blood
well i would there was like remember you
guys call it italian ice in new york we
call it water ice and we used to have
truck come around this guy don julio he
ran the truck i don't know who he was i
don't know what kind of creep but he was
funny that's all i remember and i would
steal money out of my mom's purse
and
and it wasn't easy either and i did and
whatever
like five bucks whatever it was but that
was terrible it was her build money yeah
it was her bill money and she used to
get mad at me so i remember i go to
don's right his truck it was right at
the playground right across the street
get water ice a big pretzel south philly
pretzel with all the mustard on it it
was amazing and then i give him the
money and he goes did you steal this out
of your mommy's pocket
i go how does this [ __ ] know
he knew it because he knew we were
orphans we didn't have any money you
know he was like how does this kid get
money and he every time he would say up
until i was in my 20s because this
[ __ ] was always around the playground
he would say you steal that mom's buck
and i go no i earned this one like i
finally admitted it to him later on in
life in fact the funny thing was that
the thing i'm telling you guys that i
had kneeled down with the peas under my
knees oh yeah that was because my mom
would put her purse in the living room
and she would come home from the take
from the
numbers okay and she'd come home from
the take from the bar
wow okay and she'd leave it in the
kitchen table no way so i would wake up
in the mornings before her when she was
still [ __ ] knocked down and go mama
mama
let me get a dollar
and she look around and go go get it out
of my purse yeah
and i started taking i don't down and i
started taking two dollars two dollars
and one day i took a five
i took something like a 20.
and she i think i went up to it she
[ __ ] caught it and she caught it and
she in my mother's world
she didn't understand that because all i
had to do was ask her i was
disrespectful she even said to me like
she was crying i'll never forget this
conversation
my mom's saying like are you [ __ ]
crazy if you come to the bar and she
goes why would why would i give you 20
bucks to stock beard are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] but if you come to the bar and
stock the beer
and you need 20 i give you 20. if you
need money for something
i'll give it to you and you could work
it off 20 year shot that's how cool she
was she goes i can't even look at you
it was so disrespectful it was in her
world she was shattered so she didn't
know what to do so juan made me right
like and it wasn't they didn't make me
right the stealing it was the lie
she goes and then when i asked you
that's what really took it over the
[ __ ] top if you would have said yeah
i took the 20 i would have been a little
mad just a little man but the lie to me
so i had to write 10 [ __ ] pages and
then people would come over
and they'd go what's up coco and i'd be
there right and then my mom then they
would say to my mom what's up with him
and my mom would say he's a piece of
[ __ ] yeah he's a [ __ ] mount he's a
[ __ ] malparito she's a piece of [ __ ]
he robbed ten bucks he didn't tell me so
you gotta sit there with embarrassment
the people would look at you but i
always had like my godfather or my
godmother or like a crazy friend dottie
that would come over and then they would
talk and then he'd go what's wrong with
coco and then he'd [ __ ] go off like
this guy would go host antonio what the
[ __ ] are you thinking you need 20 you
come to me
and then he'd go dinora can i talk to
him for a second and he'd take me in the
other room and he'd tell me what the
[ __ ] are you thinking if your father was
alive he'd be ashamed and i'd start
crying and he goes listen here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna go out there
and talk to your mother tell them that
you're never gonna steal again
let's go out there like a man put a
shirt on with a tie this dot they do
would make me dress up why and we'd have
to go out there and go dinora come in
here jose who wants to talk to you and
this guy would say tell him what we told
me in the room and i would have to
repeat it i'll never [ __ ] steal from
you and again i'll never lie look at her
in the face and tell like a man you
ain't no [ __ ] [ __ ] like i was like
five or six and this guy would be
coaching me through this [ __ ] and i
would have to give my mom a hug and then
i wouldn't have to write for a few weeks
wow like but that's how it was it took
like four or five days of me writing and
then one of her crazy friends i like the
writing part the writing part is
treachery taught me how to write spanish
there you go today today i know how to
read and write spanish from those but
maybe maybe that's a punishment you can
do to your daughter instead of the hands
because i hate the whole we use our
words kind of [ __ ] i hate that i like
the emotional hook and i get emotional
so i know i could [ __ ] them up with
emotion yeah my mom cries yeah you died
once you're people looking in the eye
and go this is what you did when you did
this
you [ __ ] crack it cracks you inside
you can't you can't deal with that [ __ ]
at all it's too much for me but you're
right about like a single mom with the
raisin men she had six boys so she
i mean she had a headache what's the
first thing they tell you when you go to
jail what what [ __ ] i'm not sure what
that's weird
what did the dude say when he in the
sopranos when he got out of the gym they
were eating lunch and he goes i went and
i picked the biggest blackest
[ __ ] and i started a fight with
him so it's the same thing when you have
sons you have to hit him you have to one
night lose your mind break toys stitches
stitch one of them up
bang the other one elbow the other one
like you got to be like clint eastwood
and hang them high you got to [ __ ] three
out of six of them up to show them that
listen don't ever [ __ ] get confused
and we've all done it every person who's
listened to a podcast has challenged
either or your parents at one time
that's right at one time you did
something that you thought you you
[ __ ] got the world to owe you
something and you were gonna walk in
your house and demand [ __ ] and your dad
looked in the face and [ __ ] read you
the right act and you started with your
little whippery someday i'm gonna kick
you in listen
if you could have done it you would have
done it three years ago i'll break your
[ __ ] life in three [ __ ] beasts
i'll never forget my brother he was
stupid messing around doing bad [ __ ]
whatever and he was like 16
16 yeah 16. he came in my mom's house my
mom's single mom my dad's crazy but he
lives like a couple blocks away she came
in the house he started talking [ __ ] to
her and she stood up and she punched him
right dead in the face and he had a
bloody nose and i was like yes and then
i was like i can't believe you gave
billy a bloody nose and he's that big
you know he's a big kid and she goes it
wasn't from me it was from the coke he
was doing i was like oh my god how does
she know but they know everything and
she was like you're not coming in here
talking [ __ ] i'll knock you out and she
did she gave him a bloody nose right in
his face
i know how to raise a child till 10 or
11.
what comes later is why i lose it
because
i have to treat him the way i was raised
well which was lumps and bumps and all i
could do is tell you so when you come
back to me and go what that that that
i told you to do it this way
the most important thing in this life is
ears
yeah until you get those ears until you
believe in trust and the guys ahead of
you
you know it's like when you first got
into comedy or something
there was always that one guy that gave
you a shortcut well look where that one
guy is today there's no shortcuts there
are no there's no shortcuts in any any
occupation whether it's want to be an
attorney we'll do it this way i only
read the line and okay yeah yeah you'll
have to go back you either pay me now or
pay me [ __ ] later yeah so it's just
uh
parenting after a certain age for me
it's going to be very rough
well they have to learn you have to be
willing to let them what's the pot learn
their own mistakes
have the yeah right what's the pot
episode in my house by then it'll be
legal what it doesn't matter what's that
what's the questions gonna be
what are the questions gonna be do you
answer to them that yeah one time i went
out with lee and we snorted two eight
balls and we got this chinese chick to
suck my dick you know your daughter sees
that she's got a story maybe save that
for later do you tell that story at
their
is the quinceanera
that remember remember two things you
hearing and you seeing is two different
things yeah
you know two different [ __ ] things i
saw my mom doing bumps guys but you you
also can't forget what you did growing
like you okay you saw your mom doing
that so you're the change you're not
going to do that in front of your kid
right well the whole no no i don't do it
now but what i'm saying is right but i
mean even the briefer yeah you know even
something as the reefer you you don't
wanna
you don't want to go there with your
kids it's like no opening up a little
door and you're not going to be able to
close it so where are you going to smoke
by that time listen she already looks at
me when i go outside
she's not [ __ ] stupid they know
you're doing something daddy that's
right
i know the look she looks medicinal
perfume i know the way she looks like
she just when i open the door
and she checks me out for a minute and
she goes back to what she's doing
that's the look i had when my mom would
come would say i gotta go in the
bathroom i gotta do something same
[ __ ] look yeah i saw it at the house
and i didn't like it at all when i was
eight or nine
and i knew my mom had done the bumps oh
my god my blood pressure would go up as
a child and i wasn't allowed to say
something no well it was her roof if i
would have said something i would have
got my head busted
but i dealt with what i had to deal with
and uh no that's a tough thing right
there and having girls
you could just talk to them
yeah
well yeah girls are a little
bit easier to talk to i think i mean it
doesn't matter everybody's going to go
out and try their own thing but you got
to be willing to let them learn on their
own like i feel like a lot of yeah go
out with that miniskirt you're going to
learn once you get 10 guys to blow a
train through you and [ __ ] in the
morning
i mean experimental with like drugs and
[ __ ] kids are going to do that no matter
what you can never
prevent that we all did it you know what
i mean we always crazy
thinks they're a genius and they do it
right under your [ __ ] nose because
i've heard today obviously 10 parents of
people i grew up with they found that
kids are doing one friend of mine called
me when they go because they're in
denial that's what it is one friend of
mine had a 19 year old daughter
and he called me one day and he's like
can i you have five minutes i don't know
even i can't show this to my wife he
found her a diary
and she was doing threesomes in high
school
oh
and he's like
right in my house
i'm upstairs sleeping out downstairs at
four in the morning doing [ __ ] pills
they were they had prescriptions for uh
uh the pain at the time vicodins yeah
they were kids eating vicodins and
having sex parties in his basement he
could not believe it
this is 20 years ago well then that's
the question like if you're gonna be
lenient how lean are you going to be
because then if you're too lenient then
people go crazy
yeah
it's there's got to be a happy medium
this is why i don't carry the full term
i'm sorry i can't do it
it's too worrisome god bless you for
doing it
i can't listen
what do you think that me and her walk
to a pharmacy and said let's do this no
nobody wants to have a kid when you're
50 [ __ ]
god just throws a little [ __ ]
curveball at you to make it interesting
that's a curveball yeah it's a [ __ ]
shot
that's a beautiful curveball beautiful
but if anybody has that in their life
and they're a parent how do you
i don't know like
when i was a kid i go to parents houses
and on the weekends the parents would
have parties and get [ __ ] hammered
those kids are [ __ ] up today like once
your parent even knows like once a key
even knows you're getting hammered on
the weekends and you're coming home and
you're using that word hungover yeah oh
i got a half a bag on and your kid looks
at you like well i'm gonna have a half a
bag on some [ __ ] day you know what
i'm saying i mean it just makes [ __ ]
sense so i don't even like booze in my
house there's a thing of vodka yeah
there's a can of beer in case she ever
makes a broken boil
the cuban rice and chicken that vodka
that kalua has been in that freezer for
two [ __ ] years
yeah i don't drink i mean i drink once
in a blue moon but i i'm lucky i didn't
get hooked on that i just know one thing
i'm not a dummy
and i know that karma repeat i'm no phi
beta kappa i'm no child psychologist but
i did
i did some things that were gene
passed on well i just told lee at five
yes lee
yes lee yes lee yes lee you know what i
was already putting
you know
always trying to make money
i was always at that age putting three
dollars away 400 away for a paid day i
always was gonna buy something big
and then again i got hooked on pacifiers
i had a pacifier i was like six or seven
i'm walking around like 800 singles and
quarters in my room dude you would get
killed a pacifier
no no but i wouldn't walk around with
the pacifier this was my plan i'd stash
them in different strategies parts i'd
even have two or three at the park and
when things got heavy
i called the timeout and i may believe i
was looking for something and i'd suck
the pacifier give it two or three good
sucks and put it right back under the
rock and go mingle and everybody i don't
even
know how to handle this what happens if
you're out walking making a deal on the
name of your pacifier what do you mean
like if you're like out and making like
out doing your [ __ ] like like feeling
good at that time i wasn't making i was
playing i used to steal teachers
editions of books and sell them to kids
that's hysterical
can you [ __ ] at that age i remember
them calling my mother and going what's
he's running with business he's running
a business he's running a business
selling and i would take the toys from
the lunch and i would lock them in and
everybody had to give me a dime
or i wouldn't give the toys back in the
sandbox i was treacherous treacherous
debbie dominguez had like six gorilla
puerto rican brothers for a quarter for
a quarter she'd get a 45 single lift
their shirt up and put it over the titty
and the nipple would pop out of the hole
for a quarter in the first grade this is
what i was doing i was just good people
you're having a show
no no just me and her under the [ __ ]
monkey bars and then i banged my head on
the monkey bars one day and that was it
no more monkey i love the monkey bars i
used to hang upside down on my knees
flip around like a momo
and then i kept getting in trouble i
kept fighting in the neighborhood my mom
had but the biggest thing i did to lift
my mom was getting hit in the head with
a lunch container the lunch box the the
thing of the therapist yeah yeah the old
school they used to have glass in the
thermoses yeah no i never had any of
that one day i got hit in the head with
a [ __ ] thermos in central park i got
five stitches in my head and i had to
run home like a little [ __ ]
bleeding [ __ ] all over the place and my
mother had come from the city then there
was a fight with a haitian dude rudy who
the father held me and beat me up what
he brought me upstairs and my mom pulled
the knife on him and chased him up the
stairs and they called the cops but the
lady next door was cuban so she said my
mom didn't see a knife so nobody went to
jail
this was a rocking [ __ ] some kid from
the podcast just went and took pictures
went all the way upstairs to 3a and took
pictures of the building oh for real
yeah somebody just recently went i get
pictures sent all the time of sacred
heart school boys oh yeah we got picture
center 205 west 88
you talked about on stage going to
brigadien castle i don't know dude
i never had so much fun than when my dad
took us to brigadien castle and and my
brothers did what you guys did what your
friends did or whatever i did without my
friends okay they were they were kids
from passaic like black that's right
when you go there during halloween
season they cater to people after six
but between three and six in those days
your your school would pay like uh for
20 tickets this is yeah 30 years ago oh
you weren't we did that it was just my
dad and he he loved to scare us if we
this if we wet our pants
he loved it like he loved to he i don't
go in the ocean because of him he bit my
toe under the water i never went in i
never went back in he says it was him i
don't believe it i don't like it i don't
like it so he took me to the uh
brigantine castle and i'm with my idiot
six brothers right and there was
remember the part where you go through
and it's like rats
you feel the tails on your ankle
[ __ ] and they had the noise
whatever and i was like god damn it and
i'm freaking my dad's laughing i'm like
this [ __ ] right he hates uh we
would climb him my little sister was on
his back edie and bobby my brother he
loved it he just loved it took it all in
but charlie and johnny didn't like to be
scared and when that guy jumps out or
somebody jumped out and i think he had
an axe they beat the [ __ ] out of him we
got in trouble and we got kicked out
i've never seen anything like that i
won't go to those things you don't jump
at somebody why do you guys go to those
things no no no no no no no no no no no
no no this my dad did it because he hated
me i went one time and i saw them beat
up dracula and i never went black only
black people would beat up [ __ ]
dracula
well my brothers did too i got to be
honest that beating was when they were
dragging him
yes come on [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
and he's like ah
i don't know my guy was dracula he had
max i don't know it was great and that
[ __ ] i told him on stage he did that was
a funny thing the city limits in north
bergen by 38th street park you signed
your name there was a hut in there
there was a hut inside 38th street park
it's still there and mr kettle worked
that [ __ ] and you'd sign your
[ __ ] name and then on monday night
july 8th a bus would come and they'd
give you a little bag with salami
sandwiches and a milk and like a [ __ ]
apple
and you got on the bus and you went to
yankee stadium and they took the whole
[ __ ] park to yankee stadium that park
28th street park like 20 people from
each park that signed up first that's
amazing and you went with your parent
and you went down there and it was like
bat night and they made you sit all the
way up on top and this is what you need
30 [ __ ] kids from each park in north
bergen
little [ __ ] two feet bats this was
this is what you did as a township
you took your kids to [ __ ] you know
the all-star team where it made many
basketball all-star what did they do
with the scary part we're just saying
that they took you to places
they took us there the one time they
took this there uh bring it to the
brigantine castle wherever it was
somewhere in one of those places and i
get there and there's 18 different those
yellow buses each one that they're
representing a different school district
yeah this was like messiah east orange
and these black kids weren't [ __ ]
around
and they were in front of us and black
people don't like to be they were in
front of us at that at that age i had
already hung out with tons of black
people i was but there was kids on that
in that school that weren't after as
many brothers as i was i yeah yeah 148
whatever but it was really funny there
was this one christmas tournament that
we played at
that my friend
they had two brothers juan from
juan rodriguez but his brother they were
both juan carlos rodriguez okay so one
was one and the other one was carlos
juan's hair went straight back so carlos
wanted his head to stay go to straight
back one
one died in 1987 got rested sober carlos
he just came to see me when i did miami
improv three or four years ago
and we're playing east arms the ghosts
from east arms now because of the size
of our high school students we played
all the black schools oh wow
east orange patterson east side
patterson kennedy you look at north
bergen's schedule from the 80s you're
like what the [ __ ] bayonne
these all had jersey city these all
[ __ ] and then the district was
hoboken and at that time hoboken was no
nobody was drinking margaritas and hope
and belvedere's nagging out right you
know hoboken was with sinatra hoboken
from sixth street down was black people
and everything else was in town killer
yeah
the good old days
so i never forget a christmas tournament
we used to [ __ ] bust
carlos's balls
and call him eddie monster because he
had the peak and everything and we
played basketball eddie look at he must
have dog don't we gotta call me eddie
monster and disrespect me and [ __ ]
so i'll never forget i'm gonna i'm like
the sixth man
freshman year i'm sitting there waiting
to go in and carlos gets and they make
him defend the ball on the way out on
our side so carlos has to stand on the
baseline and there's a black kid getting
the ball
but while he's waiting for the ball he
takes a look at carlos and he yells at
his partner he goes yo look at this
[ __ ] he looks like dracula
and we on the bench were like ah we just
[ __ ] lost it
a black kid we've been telling you for a
year you look like eddie monster you
tell us no this [ __ ] just called
you dracula we we weren't thinking
around
everything happened when we went into
those neighborhoods like all those funny
[ __ ] things absolutely listen i've
never been beat in my life
you know where i got beat yeah camden
new jersey oh camden's pretty rough but
two pounds a pot for 1800 hours i paid
that [ __ ] with a vig to the end
because his paddy d had to give him his
[ __ ] money back you know i was like
i thought i was johnny [ __ ] reefer
how did they get you
they usually don't let you live too long
well reefer i guess it's the higher up i
met them on the street
they came up to me i said i wanted to
get high what's happening was cracking
they had a badass [ __ ] car
four black dudes got out of the car i
was hanging out in the [ __ ] jersey
city one night at some [ __ ] bar i was
about 16 or 17
and there was some dudes hanging out
outside i went to smoke and joined they
came over yeah i'm like hey blood you
want to get high [ __ ] yeah what do you
got now tell me about this chocolate
thai weed and i smoked a joint and i was
[ __ ] up
i was [ __ ] up guys this was something
out of this [ __ ] world
then they showed it to me and i was like
jesus [ __ ] christ
look at that stuff what type of numbers
you looking for
and they told me the numbers they won i
said listen i only got like 18 bucks on
me 20 bucks what can i get for that they
gave me a tremendous butter this [ __ ]
and i went to this dude patty dear
neighborhood guy and i said patty d
this is what they want i attacked on you
know i was johnny mafia yeah yeah i
tacked on six to the bill i was gonna
walk out of there with 12
but i didn't have the front cash
so he goes what do you want for the two
pounds i said whatever the [ __ ] i wanted
18.
i called the guys and they said meters
whatever off of uh some [ __ ] gas
station off the three or something like
that okay and i went over there i met
him i got out of the car handshakes hugs
the whole [ __ ] deal
they showed me the bag
i don't know how they did it wait till
this day
we hugged what's up dog oh yeah this is
in the beginning of the new [ __ ] you can
supply this every week yeah yeah yeah
they helped me they [ __ ] manipulated
me dog
i gained the money
and they showed it to me
and then something happened they did
like a magic [ __ ] act
like they turned around
and they gave me that bag and they go
dog it's hot around here go to the car
put in the trunk and just get the [ __ ]
out of here
so i got in the car drove away and like
two or three miles i was like hold on
let's take a look at this [ __ ]
and when i [ __ ] looked in the bag it
was just bricks of dirt oh you got his
[ __ ] and i [ __ ] chased them
and nothing i called the number
disconnected i mean of course it was
like a pay phone they were working out
of it was [ __ ] brilliant how they got
me they said black magicians black
magicians the same ones that robbed the
red band didn't he get robbed
was it right now no oh a long time ago
by a black wizard
that's hysterical that's always been
like where you're from
that's always been when i was growing up
i used to go down there for concerts and
[ __ ]
from asbury park down that was always
kind of scary for me it turned [ __ ]
real once you got into i used to go to
concerts in philly
tons of them i live a half a mile from
where the vet's standing i don't know
how many sixer games i went in philly
but i gotta tell you if i had to count
them between five and seven or eight wow
i went in 83 i was a [ __ ] i was down
that dog i think i went to one with my
dad
a half of one he had a pick up money
from somebody
and we just got i went by
meet julius irving
and that was me and my brother billy and
we were like oh my god
and we were so little his hand was
bigger than our arms
and we just shook our hand my dad got
whatever he got we left i don't remember
watching the game
but i could have been too little i don't
know
i don't remember it it's vague i just
remember julius and being like oh [ __ ] i
went to one of his basketball clinics
put on by converse oh okay we all waited
online like a bunch of jackalopes then i
was about 10 or 11. that [ __ ]
pulled up in the mercedes benz
[ __ ] palm in the basketball i almost
came all over myself the greatest i
loved all that [ __ ] i loved all that
basketball [ __ ] growing up in philly i
loved baseball too basketball baseball
and they used to have to come to our
neighborhood because ours was like the
okay neighborhood to go in so they would
come in our neighborhood like the
phillies and the sixers and the eagles
and never hockey really but they would
come in our neighborhood and hang out
with the kids like for a day and then if
you were good
uh they would let you go in there and
i'm very once in a while a kerrigan kid
would sneak through so i got snuck
through one time and i was having a
catch with tug mcgraw
he used to be a
picture amazing
tremendous so wait so i had him when he
was a met
wow he was a met in 73. he was my
favorite he was my mom
tug mcgraw was a man now was tough
mcgraw what's his name's father yes and
he never talked to him they've never
spoken yeah there's something weird
there well anyway why'd you keep the
[ __ ] name because it's a great name
we were having a catch right and he uh
this was when i cut my hair off because
i was transitioning at that point i
wanted to be a boy for sure and i
literally i we were having a catch and
he looked at somebody goes hey this
little boy's got an arm and i was like
it's working it's working he thinks i'm
a dude
i literally cut my hair and played
like a boy
i really did i always wanted to be bruce
jenner now he wants to be me the [ __ ]
up [ __ ] we doing with children when did
he play for the mets he started in 66
and he played till 73 uh
he was so cute my mom loved it my mom
was a beer girl for the phillies and the
eagles for years i think 74.
because in 73 he was real vocal but he
had a weird way of pitching he was
[ __ ] he would get all fired up and
[ __ ] he was like the first rodgers
yell from the [ __ ] mound of people
who [ __ ] say [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
must have been great growing up in
philly in those days it's my favorite
place in the world i go home in a couple
years now is it gentrified
yeah there's
a couple areas which is fun to watch if
you go home like on pachunk avenue uh
where you'll still see like the good
fellas on one side and then
these idiots in their tight pants and
rolled up on the other side i'm like
somebody's gonna get killed let's just
watch the fun you know because there's
no reason for them to be in that
neighborhood but they're trying to clean
it up and ride their bicycles around
like hey
about putting cameras up and [ __ ] you
know on the other side they're getting
pissed off because they're putting
cameras everywhere it's just weird it's
just they're not my mom's neighborhood
though it's still the same
it's still the same
there's so many pockets in south philly
that are still
exactly the same
and that's why i love it
i love the old neighborhoods i lived in
the italian section of boston
and i had this neighborhood lived there
for like 40 50 years
and was
convinced that we were stealing from her
and we we were like
no oh
we broke into our uh
her storage closet like we don't have a
storage closet
i know you have i'm like and i was like
but it was just like they've been there
forever it was it's great yeah my mom's
been in the house from the day she got
married same house that we grew up in so
if they don't if they don't leave they
can't gentrify it too much yeah not a
lot of people leave and i don't think
they're going to want to gentrify that
neighborhood from
august like i
first time went to philly was to see the
stones
and foreigner
but from
august
of maybe
81
to like 83 i had the weirdest
relationship in philadelphia my buddy
went to glassboro
and he was a complete scam artist that
he talked me into doing paperwork
he said he knew everybody he'd get me
and he'd get me cash all right so he
went down there a couple times i slept
on his floor
we got high we watched tv great [ __ ]
kid
and sure enough he got me [ __ ]
admitted in that
got me a couple grand which i
immediately put up my nose and bought
clothes and tried to get my dick sucked
or whatever at the time i was always
getting in trouble in north bergen so
whenever i would get in trouble all i
had to do was go to kennedy boulevard
take a bus to the city and then take the
express to philadelphia yeah and i
called him and tell him i was going to
take a cab over there and he'd feed me
and i'd hang out with him for a few days
and we'd scam [ __ ] and he kept me in
there for a semester did you know wow so
for a semester i walked around
where the [ __ ] uh
a glass barrel is which is not rowing
he got me a job roofing
wow work for these [ __ ] dudes and all
i did all day was carry 90 pound rolls
up a ladder they paid me 50 cash at the
end of the day
which to me
meant more than anything in the world
just the fact that i'd have to wait a
whole [ __ ] week for my money yeah
every day at five he'd pay you 50 bucks
if you worked after five he'd give you
65 or whatever the [ __ ] it was seven
o'clock whatever
but i was just a regular i was 19 i was
always in trouble
and whenever things got heavy that i
owed somebody or i stole something i
shouldn't have stole i just hop on the
bus
and go to philly and i'd eat
and i used to [ __ ] uh i hooked up
with a girl
paisano i never forget she has said she
said a family owned the restaurant like
a a hoagie place paisano's
this is 1980 [ __ ] 182 wow
but it was just scary like there was
like one time i got raided i was just
watching a content went to see black
sabbath and the feds jumped us in
philadelphia in 83
just a bunch of crazy you went on the
lamb yeah and i just take the bus to
philly so many people do that
it wasn't the land it was just airing
something out for a few days
listen let's pretend you go to the
comedy store every [ __ ] night and i
go to the comedy store every [ __ ]
night oh i fly in and out of the comedy
store and i bring weed to the comedy
store and one day i give you two pounds
of weed and i say i'll be here next
monday and you don't show up
you're gonna sit a couple extra days and
wait for you two pounds of [ __ ] weed
or the money where's joey nobody knows
and that's what i would do nobody ever
knew i just disappeared in philadelphia
for how long three four days five days
until [ __ ] aired out if you're people
isn't enough to give up
listen
when you're mad at somebody on a monday
how mad are you still at them on friday
if they only for two pounds a week not
really that mad you've already thought
about other deals you already thought
about how you're going to beat them up
now all you're doing is putting together
a story and putting together a certain
amount of castle when you come back
there's no bad blood
so those five days
let's say you owe the guy 1800 but in
those five days you put together 1200
12.50 at least you got a story dog let
me tell you what happened i was selling
that weed the cops were around the
corner i took the wheat i went down to
philly i also held it i got 1200 but
listen give me another two pounds to get
the party started bam there you go you
follow him saying here you're always
buying time five six seven [ __ ] days
it's a stressful way to live your life
oh my god no [ __ ] why do you think i
stopped [ __ ] doing it why i think
that what do you think i ten why do you
think i turned to the sure thing of the
career of comedy because it was so
[ __ ] surely that's why i [ __ ]
because at that point that's what i had
been doing all along
this is why comedy was so easy for me
because that's what i've been doing all
along
living under [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ]
conditions and even if somebody was
looking for me somebody was looking for
me even if somebody wasn't looking for
me they were looking for me
because i was always creating some type
of chaos owing somebody for a gambling
debt robbing some drug dealer's house
robbing a regular house
and philadelphia was just a [ __ ]
escape
bubble and i think i even owed in
philadelphia too
then you have to leave there i think i
had to leave where did you go from
philly back to north bergen they ain't
gonna [ __ ] pick there was a lot of
people that did that like i had friends
in philly that would go up to new york
for a little bit hide out in the bronx
or brooklyn or wherever like they had
buddies or cousins or something and then
vice versa like people would just you
know take a break the best part of your
story is like no one ever like travels
to get their money from you
like if you're not there it's gotta be
alive people knew you were in colorado
people knew you were
like it's amazing no one ever was like
hey i'm gonna go get that money
you understand that those people from
that area go to florida or they go to
atlantic city once a year that's a big
deal i brought pictures
we went to see this band at the borgata
i don't even know what their name is
they were tremendous
and you sit there going oh this poor
bastard
i went to this bar over at this place
you should have seen this guy i mean
it's just crazy lee what what's to some
people what's an adventure so i always
knew people weren't going to get on the
[ __ ] plane
very seldom did somebody get on the
[ __ ] plane or
threaten to come out what the [ __ ] they
wait leave they wait because they always
know you're gonna come home
and they hope they get you when their
guard is down that's why you throw them
off their game
because once a person leaves they go
around they ask a few people at the ball
where's coco i don't know i haven't seen
him a few days wait a second you guys
are connected at the [ __ ] hip and all
of a sudden you haven't seen him in four
days you hear from him no listen tell
him when you hear from him that he owes
me two thousand dollars
so now everybody knows why you
disappeared because how are you all that
guy money [ __ ] it but you give him a few
days to air out right calm down and if
you do come back you come back with an
envelope in the story
as if you don't come back with an
envelope there's a problem yeah
if you come back with just a story at
least if you come back with 60 in a silk
shirt
or a [ __ ] gold watch or something
like that it's forgotten for a few weeks
and it gives you momentum nobody wants
it outstanding
if you come to me lee and you owe me 3
000 for an ounce of coke chances are i
won't give you another three thousand
right if you come to me and say joey i
only had two thousand i had to pay rent
dog this guy still owes me eleven
hundred i'll give you that
now you got three or four more days to
just make that money back on the second
ounce of coke i gave it to you
you always leave owen the guy something
because then you have an investment in
the drug dealer all those years when i
was buying coke on gardiner from the
uh
from the
martel cartel yeah i always owed a 20
march i never went in there with a full
envelope never why do you keep a tab
because then i thought they always got
to answer the phone
you understand me if you don't if you
don't keep a tab they're not going to
answer the phone oh it's this
[ __ ] like an evil genius they're
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] let me [ __ ]
this [ __ ] i'm gonna give you 50
bucks you want that 50 i owe you
yeah i want the 50 we'll open the
[ __ ] door little do they know that
you're gonna leave their own 100
you're going to give them the 50 ohm but
then you're going to front the yardstick
the martel cartel you know that was
right over here
i used to go to the market i lived on my
town i remember it right around the
corner from you i know it was up right
but you lived on my side yeah they were
up the corner yeah the black dude they
used to come to the store with the
envelope with the blonde and [ __ ]
that they had like well let me tell you
how i became friends with them just so
you [ __ ] know
at that time i used to have this little
gun i
found i found this gun and jodie furtick
was the apartment builder manager over
at 1440. how do you find a gun
you know you could find sometimes people
fighting to fight out a bill sometimes
people so i found this
guy as [ __ ]
and i hid it in the wall and martel
did you know if it worked or not or you
just absolutely you know i don't find
defective guns okay okay who finds a
defective gun so i didn't want it on me
because i'm a felon i couldn't have it
in my apartment right so i unscrewed the
mirror at jody freddie's apartment
because he always let the front door
open and i put the [ __ ] gun in her
wall for like a year the gun was on her
wall poor jody and she never knew it i
used to go to her house and hide blow
like i go to her house are you kidding
me listen i love her listen to what i
would do because i i know if i went back
she'd be up so what i would do is i'd go
to el compadre buy an eight ball take
half of it break it in half go to jody's
apartment hide half the eight ball then
i go to the store and then i call and
wake up and say jody i'm coming over you
can't i'm sleeping i got a half eight
ball over there where
don't worry i'll show you when i get
there by the time i got that cocktail
was served my shoes were taken off who's
better than me
that was a party building so anyway yeah
it's a tremendous building so anyway i
had this gun in the wall
and one night i was almost gonna beef on
911 but then something happened i went
to the martel cartel and everybody was
beat up
that's how i became goombas with him
everybody was beat up what do you mean
beat up like they got robbed oh they got
set up somebody left the gate open oh on
the way out three people went out they
came in and left the gate open and
[ __ ] 10 [ __ ] black dudes came
pistol whipped the white dude and the
black dude and the dude was just walking
in tied them up and took all their drugs
four ounces of blow couple pounds of
weed some ecstasy
so these guys are sitting there i walk
in they're sitting there all beat up
like somebody [ __ ] you know
and i walk in like where's the [ __ ] and
they're telling me you gotta wait now we
just got robbed they both got headaches
let me ask you a question how the [ __ ]
are you drug dealers that's what i got
i go don't you guys have a piece here
and they both looked at me like i was a
martian
they're like not really i go listen
you're gonna do eight years for the
drugs you might as well pick up another
two and have a piece here
you put it right next to the big bag of
blow underneath it as you're going for
the [ __ ] battle you take the gun you
shoot the guy in the [ __ ] leg if
they're robbing you this one i never
understood out of all the [ __ ] people
i robbed and that capacity drug dealers
they didn't have their [ __ ]
together so many when i lived in aspen i
had 12 guns ready to shoot at all parts
of the house if you let me bend over
there was a gun under that carpet
okay there was a gun everywhere i had
guns outside because that's how juan was
were they all loaded my step ready to
shoot my stepfather always had pieces if
my stepfather hung at the comedy store
every night
one day in the afternoon he'd go up
there and hide a gun just in case things
just in case i get it things get bad
there's always a gun close by it's not
even on your body and nobody else is
going to find it so yeah how many places
i just imagine like gunned under the mat
and from 86 to 89 when i became that
stupid gun person that i thought i
really wanted to be i bought every gun
shoot it a couple times and i'd sell it
yeah all right that's what i would do i
would get rid of them or whatever i'd
take them back to jersey and just sell
them with no paperwork [ __ ] like that so
i didn't really care but i had guns
hidden everywhere so if you came to my
house and put a gun to my head i tell
you listen come here i know where this
50 [ __ ] grand
and i'd have six guns in that area
pointing at that 50 grand
that you wouldn't [ __ ] see if you
came into my room but i was gonna go for
one of them and you were putting that
envelope in the thing i'm going to lease
them and cap you with something because
most of the people that do that are
are scared not 10 times yeah most of the
people
like that
yeah the people that heavy duty come in
they do this for a [ __ ] profession
when i was doing i wasn't no
professional i was just a [ __ ] coke
fan that wanted to rob you but you
pulled the [ __ ] gun on me i fall to
pieces
i'm gonna lie to you pull a gun on me in
those days i fall to pieces i suck your
dick
i have no [ __ ] choice seriously
that's what happens to people that's why
you suck
nobody ever put a gun to my head
quite a few what are you gonna do
let me give uh some shout outs
jason sal davari jason ellison king
julian
dead squad harlem renee and carcione
sergio ortega matt broadchick
christopher moore
and victor hernandez what are you
[ __ ] nuts or what happy labor day
[ __ ] lee how [ __ ] up are you
getting together yeah you're [ __ ] i am
very i love you so i never understood
how you could go to somebody's house and
they don't have three pieces or at least
one piece pointing at the loot okay i
gotta go to that pillowcase i got
another ten thousand for you where if he
goes in there and he grabs a gun you're
gonna have a problem so that's when you
gotta have another gun close by
ready to [ __ ] fire
ready to [ __ ] launch i mean that's
the mentality you gotta figure that
they're all out there to get your
mentality oh please but that's what the
drugs do they you know
what are you going to do this what
you're learning on monday afternoon on
labor day right right you got to learn
how to work you want smoking on a number
sure you do this is some good [ __ ]
weed perennials putting me on the
[ __ ] map
lemon oh gee kushners
i hate weed the smell of it i mean this
is let me explain i just don't smoke
anything and i'm a picky [ __ ] i know
this is a chinese girl she picks me and
i got an eighth of that the other day
yeah come on
smell like [ __ ] damn it oh my god
i know it's probably not as good as it i
could get but i get i got like one of
the pr
uh pre-rolls at sunset herbal
it was really good
but it never smells good
no just me she doesn't like smoking
she had a good time this weekend you tie
her up you give her a good start i mean
you don't shoot loads in the mouth
nothing he politely taps around the
shoulder
no
get off the helmet i'm about to come
honey [ __ ] well you make a suck that
[ __ ] rod of death siphon it out a
little jew juice comes out of there and
knocks it for a [ __ ] loop
every time she puts a ghost you have to
put glasses on to balance her head after
that
it's all over your [ __ ]
i don't know i want people to really go
see you i think that yes
you're at a point in your life where uh
comedy wise are people gonna start
seeing i think you [ __ ] made a lot of
people uh
lift their heads up what women are doing
now in 2015 and you're
in front of the pack you just need a
good push behind you need a good push
but it is good uh that i'm getting a
headline
different places now like i'm i'm
actually co-headlining in scottsdale
next weekend which one for the lab
factory okay that's good
lowell sanders good great yeah he's a
great guy
and
then in jersey that's just me just you
and that's the 25th and 26th
of september yeah i always have to look
because but also i was telling you the
pope is coming to philadelphia so
they're shutting down bridges
so all my connections from philly
he can't come
like my brother was like oh we're going
to rent a bus we're going to go see you
i was like great he's like hey there's
no buses there's nothing nothing you
can't get up because this is the
people's pope
so this is like people are flying in
fill it up people are renting their
houses out is that the only place he's
going to philly i think so i'm not sure
why but uh
and
i'm not sure exactly i mean i want to
see the pope but not what 10 million
people qualify
as a kid i sat on the stupid curb on
broad street waiting for the pope me and
my best friend we got there at like six
in the morning it was already a bunch of
people there but we were little so we
went to the front you know they let the
kids in the front and we sat there all
day and that pope flew by us so i was
like nah i'm not falling for that scam
again but this guy
i think he's you know i wouldn't be
surprised if he's like sitting in
people's houses and [ __ ] there's nothing
for two people the mailman and the ice
cream man there you go maybe the water
ice guy will be there picking on me for
stealing things well i thought about you
the other night because i saw this
periscope
apparently every time they open a
chick-fil-a if you wait outside
they'll give you free chick-fil-a for a
year so people are camping out all night
in the chick-fil-a parking lot and i
just thought i'd just i just want to
send joey diaz places
every chick-fil-a or i don't know if
it's everyone it was this you got free
for a year yeah wow
wow
i'll tell you what
i like chick-fil-a i like the chicken
cutlet you take the bread throw it away
but i went over here in hollywood yeah i
got sick both times
that one had an aftertaste i didn't like
it that's where the gays were protesting
they put the stomach they put the
[ __ ] gay whammy on that [ __ ] place
they're getting bad water
they're getting used water from one of
those gay bars now in santa monica or
some [ __ ]
they're getting something in there
i went there twice i loved it when i
lived in other than boulder was in the
mall and it was next to a place
that made lemonade with rosemary water
jesus it was [ __ ] delicious all the
ice cubes are three bucks a pop i'd go
down there spend a 20. that's what i had
the american express i didn't give a
[ __ ] in those days i knew it was going
down anyway i went and drank 80 [ __ ]
iced teas just like oh my god so many
credit card things oh my god i've been
through so many credit cards some of
them are still chasing me most of them i
paid off
the ones from 90 they just i had like 15
of them
and then i didn't touch him at least i
never i never thought about it and then
when i got separated before i got
separate i went to new york for 10 days
10 days rented a police car i took cash
advances like johnny bananas there you
go 200 a pop you know what that's like
when you go get your bill
oh my god
i remember i had that i couldn't even
get more more cash advances they were
like what are you [ __ ] kidding me
you're out of cash
and i got the first bill i owe them my
triple that those cash advances oh yeah
because they charge you for that or they
used to charge i don't know
yeah
they tack it to the prince they do
something weird are those blank checks
they send oh those blank checks [ __ ]
that those blank checks saved my [ __ ]
one night
saved my [ __ ] two nights and [ __ ]
because i found them in the draw oh you
know when you're looking going for a
draw looking for a pen yeah yeah you're
like ho ho ho what have we found here
and i owed a bunch of money i was living
in boulder i was just starting comedy
and they had a 24-hour drive dress let
me take a chance i wanted some coke this
is the last hope
i got to check for a thousand that went
right to the [ __ ] draw and i would
discover oh at that point i would
discover everything with the kitchen
sink they were calling me everywhere
ever i went over to the bank and gave
the check on a saturday night and went
over when they came back and they said
how do you want in hundreds of twenties
i said nothing but ben franklin's
i took that thousand dollars and i ran
out of that drive through window do you
know they called me at 901 on monday
morning oh you're authorized to take
that money back immediately
immediately
you were not supposed to be given that
[ __ ] loot
and your response was up
it's gone i didn't answer the phone you
better go get it back from the colombian
because that's gone
i [ __ ] got a cash
in mexico
those people chased me for [ __ ] years
and you know what they did
discover is nasty they went after the
bank okay and even though i owed the
bank i had an accurate integra
that i had [ __ ] gotten i got divorced
i really wanted an acura integra with a
badass stereo system
that's the car i [ __ ] him was going to
the denver nugget game and i [ __ ] hit
black ice and i banged up the rims
and then my big deal was to
to bust into the mike kessler's car shop
and boulder
subaru and take a car bring it to my
garage take the tires off and put it on
my car can you imagine me coming to you
and going
i don't know you're the general manager
of that accurate place do me a favor
give me the keys i was like seriously
give me the keys
and he's like joey they're gonna [ __ ]
know yeah and then something happened i
had to leave and i left them when i came
back
they went this is how nasty discover was
discover was gonna sue the bank for the
thousand bucks
because they gave me the thousand bucks
without checking something yeah the bank
automatically no matter what i owed them
gave me a loan for 24 months
to pay back that thousand bucks and they
tacked it on to the acura that i had oh
and when they reconditioned the acura i
owed this much
they were calling everywhere the balance
was like four thousand dollars they were
[ __ ] looking for it i never paid them
they must have
figured it out
what a [ __ ] shame they ripped off
some other push i was very [ __ ]
fortunate man
but what are you gonna do that's what
happens eleanor goes on the road i beat
the [ __ ] discover people and that's
it i won't even and they keep sending me
[ __ ] discover open up an account oh yeah
[ __ ] look yeah i don't even [ __ ] with
them capital one
don't [ __ ] around
who
the toughest white people in the game
gaming my card back like nothing
in fact they looked me up
amex
what
i they cut mine in half i can't get that
back after 24 years they gave me a call
and said where you been doing
you ain't that
people have misunderstandings hey
we take care of them but now if you like
your card back and we're going to give
you a nice limit it's yours i was like
come on i thought it was limitless
i don't know what
that's right it is limitless something
crazy i don't think all of them are
limitless yeah something's crazy
something
mx that's what i got in trouble for
because there was no limit i figured out
how to get cash advances
every month do you know you can't get
you have to pay whatever you spend the
whole no [ __ ] yeah you know that you
have you can't get cash advances in an
american express card but guess what
uncle joey figured out how you gotta go
gotta go to a
casino go right to the
cashier no no
the
bank the pit bull pit boss boss i talk
to you for a second listen
i got this monkey on my back and i'm
feeling lucky as [ __ ]
gonna play blackjack
my card's got 11 000 on it but i'm out
of cash advances
can you help me out let me get the card
up go walk away and come back and go go
get five thousand dollars
it's like automatic
in the old days i don't know about now
that's funny
i like it in vegas in the old days they
would bump your credit card they could
call yeah
vegas could call
deadly for everyone can you imagine that
and i'm talking 20 and they never did it
for me i'm not saying this they did it
for me i heard from friends of mine that
they'd be they'd have a 3500 limit and
they'd be at 3 300. and you go up to a
pit boss and go here's my situation pit
ball should say give me the [ __ ] car
i'll be right back i got you up to five
g's that was i don't know how they did i
don't know if it's true don't quote me
on this well tolkien lair said uh if you
have the money like if you have money
what people will do is they'll come in
and get like money from the casino
like a cash advance or whatever it is
play a couple hands win it back and just
give it back to the casino then they
have like a three or four thousand
dollar
free trip on the casino but you have to
actually have the money
so if you didn't have the money that we
are so we'll say that again so we fly in
flying i leave my credit card i forget
what it's called but it's like when you
go in
and they uh they give you money like
they give me a lot of credit or
something right i know you get credit
you can file paperwork right
so then you get 20 grand and then like
you'll go to like play blackjack or
something win a couple hands
and get to like 25 000 dollars if let's
get a 20 000 line of credit
play it to 25 and then just give the 20
000 back to the casino and then you have
five grand to play with
but i can't do that [ __ ] interesting
that's what my life i i can't
i don't have the balls to do that
yeah it could backfire on you i can't
sleep at night we'll pull the move like
that because those [ __ ] always
collect their [ __ ] eithers you
know what i'm saying you can't leave
vegas no i can't i can't do it i don't
have the stomach i don't know i used to
but this [ __ ] up how they kick like
people like ben affleck out and yep
people who play a lot and i kick them
out
his wife calling on him
so they kicked ben affleck out
um uh like the hard rock or something
why i think he was kind of cards or
something i don't know um he was doing
too well no it was something shady
definitely and they were just uh
they do that a lot they kick out a lot
of people they really do i mean
a lot of people do have scams it's crazy
i'm not saying he was cheating i'm not
saying he wasn't i'm saying
somebody ratted on him i wouldn't have
the balls to go into a casino and
cheating you know i've done some crazy
things
i don't know how people well they're
always watching you yeah always watching
always i think even in the bathroom
that's watching you i agree i've done
blood
petrified pet your fight they're gonna i
would go into the bat and turn the light
off get a hat with a light on it make me
believe i was doing bumps anyway
let's talk about some [ __ ] great
magazine stuff
for those of us who want premium content
don't have time
to waste finding it you know what there
is there's a thing called next issue
next issue is a mobile app that lets you
tap directly into the world's most
popular magazines
anytime anywhere using your phone
your tablet okay
iconic magazines like people vogue
esquire time
that type of stuff high level for people
like to wear glasses and little hats and
goatees
actually let you dive deeper into the
story with interactive content for
richer reading experience sign up for
next issue right now i'll tell you what
i'm going to get you immediate access to
all the top magazines including back
issues that's the clinker back issues
and exclusive videos and photos
they have the best contents around and
the topics i care about the most you
know what like let's say you love
architecture whatever they got hot rod
magazine they got self they got 17. me
you know me i'm a rolling stone type of
[ __ ] dude i like people i like the
little gossip in the front i'm not into
golf digest but if you get it i ain't
going to be mad at you they got fortune
they got cycle world they got domino
they got everything they got l do me a
favor all right and i you know i'm not
here to [ __ ] tell you what to do the
best part is next issue is offering a
free trial right now when you go to next
issue dot com slash joey all right do me
a favor just go there and check out what
you got lee loves it he don't [ __ ]
fly unless he uses it he says he goes to
his phone you download the magazines you
want yeah or you're out on the [ __ ]
plane and there you have it and again
listen you can try this for free right
now when you go to next issue.com slash
joey i mean why are we [ __ ] around
here i'm giving you something for free
get on the cuff speaking of free
honor.com you know what honey.com gives
you gives you a free [ __ ] spirit it
gets you strong gets you healthy gets
your blood pressure down it gives you
energy to last the extra today i got to
tell you i lasted a couple [ __ ]
rounds in jiu jitsu you want me to sit
here and tell you i've been working hard
i did the kettlebells yesterday and
stuff but i took my little [ __ ]
shroom tech sport and every day gives me
a little bit more of an edge i'm not
bullshitting whether it's the shroom
tech whether it's the sport whether it's
the immune whether it's the hem protein
which i love 16 grams per scoop two
scoops 32 [ __ ] grams that's all your
body needs right there times five you
got 150 [ __ ] uh milligrams of protein
you're walking around like [ __ ]
johnny hercules who's better than you do
me a favor go to honor.com right now
look at the great selection of [ __ ]
nutrients they got from the t-booster
to the to the little fatty thing that
you had the coconut world that you had
mct or go there right now go there pick
something go to the box and press in
church
and get 10 off just like that and if you
stay on it you got additional 10 off and
it gets mailed directly to your house no
more [ __ ] around
you like shroom tech what the [ __ ] you
like it let's get it sent every [ __ ]
week here every other week so i know
when i go to jiu jitsu when i ride my
bicycle when i go to [ __ ] uh whatever
this [ __ ] with people jumping ropes and
flying over walls i got my energy do me
a favor go to honor.com right now and
press in church boom and you stay on and
hang out hit e6 [ __ ] the best
the best e-cig out there in the market
you know why 1200 guaranteed pups okay
1200 what do you think those [ __ ]
terrorist cigarettes you guys get at
7-eleven they're gonna [ __ ] save you
this is the way to go and right now
they're running a tremendous deal 86 you
get five for five five for fifty i'm
sorry each one is ten bucks what do they
use legally like eighteen yeah those are
twenty they're hooking you up because
you know why because you're family with
the [ __ ] church i'm with you you're
with me there with us do me a favor all
the haters state right now quit smoking
with the [ __ ] electronic cigarette
you go from 24 milligrams to 16 to 8 to
zero and they throw in the cigar five
for [ __ ] 50 who's better than you go
to 86 right now and press in joey's
church boom and get that deal
and don't forget nailed it life you
[ __ ] wax heads you want to get the
blowtorch the rock they got everything
there and they got those gummies and
monos which are now these little [ __ ]
white tablets of death they look at the
things that moses had with the ten
commandments the slots you eat those
[ __ ]
tremendous flavors and nice and sweet
and they get you [ __ ] up these guys
know how to make a great animal go to
nail their life.com and press in joey
diaz boom and there you go you get 20
percent off the best mate preparing the
market all right nice and easy next
issue if you're not messing around with
the next issue you're slipping it's the
future right there in your tablet on
your phone indirect the whole thing on
it you're healthy here these things
you're puffing till your face is [ __ ]
blue
and nailed it life if you want to smoke
some wax
and that's it lee you're going to sit
there like the tumor [ __ ] that the
what's going on with you there beautiful
i'm happy you came on thank you so much
for having me i love doing this because
this podcast just you talk about
anything and i [ __ ] work hard i see
you out there
walking around and that's all that
matters to me just doing it you dove in
for this it took you a while to get in
it but once you dove into it
it's like a chick that switches
governments you know what i'm saying
right
full-blown now what what's up with you
tonight what are you doing you want a
jiu jitsu at eight o'clock why don't you
go to time hell dude what you'd be
perfect but it's five o'clock by the
time you go to
8 30
quarter tonight you get it out of the
way it's money you think this is going
away into reality [ __ ] it it's not that
it's going away you're making it go away
because you're lisa
you're that type of [ __ ] jew
you understand me if they want to fake
you go to beverly hills they're walking
around with sandals giggling
you're not that type of jew you come
from the old school
you threw the rocks you got hit by the
rocks you are the right
you know what i'm saying get it together
how many times
what's crack-a-lacking eleanor yes some
of these [ __ ] that they could
find these sexy things you can find me
right here no i'm just kidding you find
me uh on facebook on twitter
ejcarrigan.com also my email i mean
what's it called the website
eleanor
jaycarrigan.com yeah yeah
but then i'm going to be in jersey on
the 26th the 25th and the 26th so if the
pope
is in preventing you stop with the
[ __ ] pope they come from that
direction
well i'm just saying they're afraid to
come out
i don't i don't think and then when i go
to philly i'm taking you to philly
hopefully next february or march yeah
you come home you see your family we got
the family out there jumping up and down
they're out of their minds and they
would love to see you what's up with you
[ __ ] licker [ __ ] licker what are you
gonna do right now you're talking to me
i'm gonna watch another [ __ ] ten
episodes of parks and rec
i have no plans right now man
what are you doing
yeah that's not what i'm doing it's what
ain't i doing there you go i'm gonna go
home now i gotta play with the [ __ ]
lunatic until about 7 30. i got to watch
three episodes of [ __ ] uh
uh team umizoomi with the troublemakers
there's these three little [ __ ] on
there the troublemakers they knock
tables over what troublemakers they're
three little [ __ ]
two little guys they're troublemaking
but she loves it right yeah
that is a troublemaker
and she takes a bath and i'll tell you
what i think i'm going to watch tonight
bullets over broadway one of my
favorites i'm in the mood for today
how good is chas palminteri
i saw the one-man show
did he really of his uh bronx town okay
i love him no no bullets over broadway
it's woody allen no but it's still he's
the but he's the guy that's right
terrific he's terrific that's his best
all-time [ __ ] role in that when he's
trying to argue with a writer and he's
better than the writer he's telling him
what to write nobody talks like nobody
talks like that but the message the
writer [ __ ] up and he shoots him that's
how personal he takes the [ __ ] play
that is as great as that's so good that
is so i found it on youtube oh great
it's on youtube the full [ __ ] movie
bullets over broadway okay the black the
black [ __ ] the the maid with the guy
the boss oh yeah you want the good you
want the good woods give them the good
hoots and [ __ ]
from the clean bag there's two movies i
gotta watch all over again they're just
calling me you ready
bullets over broadway and harlem nights
especially after we talked about david
banks i'm ready for halloween nights
if not i got to watch the michael
jackson remember the time video it's
like 18 minutes
same thing harlem nights remember the
time what's the [ __ ] difference
people dancing jumping up and down black
snakes
i love you guys thank you eleanor hello
listen jersey my jersey people you know
i love you [ __ ] with all my
heart
friday night you go see eleanor and
stanley you come see me in the city or
vice versa when you're in uncle vinnie's
i'm in gotham
oh
i'm right there
i'm skipping the jump for you you'll
never make it 11 45 wow
shoot wait you have a look on your face
don't forget to tell them about vegas
and vegas is september 19th we're
shooting the special he's going to be
there with a little hat
salami the [ __ ] anarchy edibles a lot
of people coming a lot of people
supporting on this thank you very much
for the love and the [ __ ] why am i
talking into the mic i'm right here
i gotta pee again all this water i swear
a lot today but jesus christ
what's up dawg you're gonna go to jiu
jitsu tonight you need to go over and
just tell
do a couple of push-ups and john but
he'll teach you some [ __ ] you have a
good time
i'm gonna go thursday with him thursday
thursday's never gonna come you gotta go
wednesday night
i think you get it out of the way you
get your kettlebell in and you then you
go with the 24-hour fitness and
do your little [ __ ] thing until [ __ ]
you know your [ __ ] blows up and [ __ ]
from doing that [ __ ] elliptical you do
you love to go how can i be once a week
but that's not the only [ __ ] thing i
do you know everyone can do 80 different
classes man you go to like 180 different
clubs
kettlebells dude
yeah you do everything you're 27.
if i was 27 years old you know what i'd
be doing what i know now oh my god you
know what i'd be [ __ ] doing first of
all at 6 00 a.m i'd be [ __ ] swimming
if i was you i'd be in a pool at 601
with three times a [ __ ] week
and then on tuesday and thursday i'd be
with rashad over there i signed whatever
his [ __ ] name is doing jiu jitsu at
12 30 so you kill that
but you do the kettle that's what i'd be
doing if i was 27 easy then on saturday
and sunday you want to go with mama on
the elliptical and
bring a little ruxin park on the tablet
and look at it that's up to you
you're 27 you could do something every
day what recovery you're 27. it's not
it's not recovering you're just so much
different driving around we're driving
around you're living in the [ __ ]
neighborhood we're driving around
i don't like meeting that many people
what meeting that what people you're
gonna
that's not a gym that's a [ __ ] uh
uh they're [ __ ] the muffler over
there you do one thing
you do you walk in you do the elliptical
for a year and three months
the same thing what do you think has
happened to your resistance the same
[ __ ] thing
you're gonna look there and sit me in
the eye and still say motivate you a
year and three months
you sit there with some tablet or some
[ __ ] harvey homo show that means
nothing i could see if you sit there and
smoke a joint and work it out nothing
you sit there with no vitamins okay you
join inside 24 hours well no you smoke a
drink in a car before you go in there at
least think and write notes down or
something nothing you go in and watch
some [ __ ] bad show i'd rather you
[ __ ] go to north hollywood stretch
and walk around three times get some
vitamin d
you never know what could happen
you got to switch it up now it's time to
switch it up you're 27 years old how
much longer
how much longer what how many more days
i did 22 minutes what [ __ ] 42 minutes
you're 27 at 27 i didn't sleep
you ain't [ __ ] the agostino both of
these sleep is great
oh my god
there was a time i used to ride my bike
to swim in boulder those pictures are
great they're [ __ ] beautiful then i
ride back home and hit the bag and lift
weights
well that was your age
it sounds really hard it's not hard it's
a pizza you are so funny this oh i could
go for a piece of cake you're a young
[ __ ] man don't you love cake you're a
[ __ ] savage i love cake you're an
animal
look at you close the show [ __ ]
lee's gonna have cake
i can't have cake
why not how many points you got left
today i have no idea i didn't use any
points yet
you even eating yet today
i'm a mess
well i had a banana
cause i was coming closer thing please
she's eating [ __ ] bananas
you know that's all i need now